are we on who even knows
welcome to the 2018 midterm election
livestream we are going to have results
we are going to hear from you people in
the audience we are going to what else
are we going to do I'm up for
potentially calling in two other people
who are also doing live results shows if
I don't know who's doing stuff or what
but I'm up for doing that maybe we could
get on other people's shows people I
don't know
super chat me the contact information
for some of these other shows maybe we
can check in with them but we are going
to be doing results and already a bunch
of interesting stuff going on we are
going to get to maybe that's what we'll
do first I mean why not just check in my
plan is that we are going to dip in and
out of coverage so we've got the NBC
news stream which we can look at at any
time and we should be able to listen to
us or less and they're gonna really
intrigued up and they're gonna be glad
they forty so we've got that going on we
have the PBS news hour which I think
actually they do it's just it's less
sensationalized and I think that it's
it's a nice stream that they do so we
might look at that let's see if we have
audio from them so huge amount of
turnout I think that I think that the
engagement I was actually going to also
have the Fox News stream but for some
reason I was unable to get audio on it I
don't I don't know why it was a really
weird thing just not able to get the
audio through on the stream and we are
going to have New York Times and all
sorts of other results available so a
lot of a lot of stuff is going to be
going on today and I do look forward to
hearing from people in the audience the
phone lines are not yet open but when
they open the number will be 6 1 78 3 0
47 50 just like yesterday so why don't
we just first take a look at what we
know so far let's start with the house
all 435 seats in the house of course up
for election as they are every two years
the constant campaigning that is a
reality of
the House of Representatives and so far
Democrats have won four of those seats
of Republicans have won ten and this
really doesn't tell us too much yet
because it is indeed so early a lot of
these in very red areas things looking
very good for Republicans in Indiana I
don't think that's going to be a
surprise to anybody things looking mixed
in Florida not a surprise to a lot of
people al Lawson already winning there
in Florida's fifth District not very
shocking
we will follow what's going on in the
house let's go over to the Senate of
course the situation and the Senate is
very different than in the house insofar
as only a third of the Senate seats are
up for re-election and it is not the set
of 35 that are favorable to Democrats
so even given a so-called blue wave and
it's still early and we'll see whether
that that actually happens even given a
blue wave you have the numbers stacked
in favor of Republicans 42 Republican
seats are not even up for election this
cycle whereas 23 Democrats are safe from
potentially even losing an election so
this already systemically favors
Republicans which is why I believe that
the Democrats are not going to take over
the Senate although many people disagree
Bernie Sanders not surprisingly handily
winning already in Vermont that race is
over in Indiana this is an interesting
race because it's assumed that the
Republican Mike Braun is going to win
but if Joe Donnelly were able to pull it
off or even to do well right like right
now he only has 42% of the vote with 12%
of the vote in if he were able to even
do well in Indiana in this Indiana
Senate seat that would already signal
that it could be a good night for
Democrats still too early to say right
now Virginia Tim Kaine is with 10
percent reporting Tim Kaine is down 44
to 39 very very early there and then
Florida this is actually one I am very
interested in and we're gonna get to
Andrew Gilliam in Florida momentarily
when we go over to governor's if bill
Nelson were able to take Florida from
Rick Scott here this could signal pretty
big things for Democrats this evening
and I want to try to get down to yeah
here we go
so I don't know how familiar with
Florida you are but these three counties
down here in the lower right miami-dade
County Broward County and Palm Beach
County this is a high population
typically Democratic sort of stronghold
that obviously includes Miami and you've
got Fort Lauderdale in here and and
other areas with populations as as we
literally see them switch to blue that
typically vote for Democrats
so if Bill Nelson can stay close without
that much of these three counties
reporting he will be in a good position
now do we have initial results from
miami-dade County 6040 in favor of
Nelson only one precinct in Broward
County Rick Scott ahead they're still
sort of meaningless and just initial
results from Palm Beach County Bill
Nelson up by almost a two-to-one margin
there so that's going to be very very
interesting to watch how do I get back
to the entire Senate I guess I click up
here so Florida we're gonna be watching
and now I mean look as we were speaking
now that we have 7% reporting in Florida
bill Nelson has taken a slight lead
there so it's gonna be a while until we
know what happens there and then we also
have some initial numbers in Ohio where
incumbent Democratic senator sherrod
Brown is up by a more than two-to-one
margin against Republican challenger
James Renacci we'll be watching that one
closely as well now let's go over to
governor's seven Democrats and seven
Republicans are who are currently
governor's are safe because they are not
up for re-election but otherwise there
are a lot of races here I am very very
interested in Florida and as we zoom
into Florida and we see that Andrew
Guilhem currently is up by two and a
half percentage points over on DeSantis
i'm already excited because this would
just be a major major win it would be a
major win number one because Florida's a
very high population state it would be a
major win number two because Florida is
also a state which can be a signal state
for what we might expect in other parts
of the country and same sort of logic
applies you've got Palm Beach County
Broward County and miami-dade County in
the southeast of the state those are
typically big Democratic strongholds
Andrew Gilliam way up basically
mirroring if you actually look at the
Palm Beach and the miami-dade numbers
gillum's nut support basically mirrors
bill Nelson's support and we still have
just very very little data from Broward
County which which really my
understanding based on looking at prior
year elections is that Broward County
should go for the Democrats and if it
doesn't it's probably not a good night
for Democrats so we're gonna be
following that very closely and zooming
back out to the entire country we've got
some early numbers in New Hampshire
where you have Molly Kelley challenging
Chris Sununu currently up but only two
percent reporting I would be interested
to see what happens there incumbent
Republican Phil Scott up in Vermont in
Ohio you of Richard Cordray up Bigley
over Mike DeWine but these are initial
results and they mean nothing we can't
really do Sen ething in South Carolina
we have under 1 percent reporting in
Georgia now Georgia I'm very interested
in and this has been the center of can
can I say it any other way than a voter
suppression Fiasco where you have the
guy who's running in the race Brian Kemp
the Republican nominee also managing the
election because he's Secretary of State
and we've seen everything from so-called
investigations into possible democratic
hacking of voter registration we have D
registration voter purges as I like to
call them limiting of voting hours early
voting hours limiting of polling places
all sorts of stuff and
if indeed this one went to Stacey Abrams
you have no idea how huge it would be
now unfortunately with only one percent
reporting Stacey Abrams has under 30
percent of the vote but it is still very
very early there and we are going to be
following that extraordinarily closely
let's see what's on people's minds so
far
Quinn Reid sent a $2 super chat saying
Gilliam supporter in the chat fellow
Floridians yeah I am excited about
Andrew Gilliam not just because he
recently actually visited the law firm
of our friends at Levin Papantonio and
number one everybody said he's just an
awesome guy and a really really nice guy
and it's just such an important race if
Democrats could take over such a large
population state that is not a reliably
blue state in Florida that would be
absolutely absolutely huge so I am very
excited about that one and I'm going to
be watching it very very closely let's
see what's happening let's just see
what's going on on PBS NewsHour's their
prosperity they see it as a beacon of
hope and we understand that we are a
country that's welcoming to immigrants
we bring in a million new immigrants a
year and he's saying let's do it legally
and let's fix our system but we
certainly don't want bad actors to get
in because we don't have the border
security right so completely standard
right wing talking points I have no idea
who this is but they sound like standard
right wing talking points about
immigration see what's going on on NBC
News by the way is megyn kelly
going to be appearing here I know that
she was scheduled to and then she lost
her show for reminiscing about when it
was okay to dress up his blackface I
don't know kind of a Stockholm Syndrome
there so the party shrunk it's always
obviously in more lockstep with the
president but I will also say the the
the Democrats who run as who as they are
progressives like Beto
live all right well not nothing too
exciting going on Georgia commute this
interestingly so let's go back to our
map because we have I go back I believe
it's to the Senate even though the
official results right now in Virginia
have
kein basically in a tie the networks
have already called it for Tim Kaine and
they're saying that that that that's it
that's it for Virginia and very very
quickly you are starting to see the
power of incumbency and we are going to
start getting I think that by 8:30 we're
actually going to have a pretty good
sense of of what the map looks like and
really what the kind of key races are
are going to be on ie 77 sends a
five-dollar super chat saying David you
so handsome
well thank you so much on AE I
appreciate that and I hope my political
analysis is sufficient as well because
otherwise that would be really really
embarrassing okay maybe I will
open up the phone lines just to hear
from people a little bit and see what's
going on although I am NOT going to be
taking calls endlessly because I know
people don't like that but let's take a
little bit of a listen to what's going
on with the audience and thank there we
go home and getting myself at six one
seven eight three zero you're going to
be your question ready number David to
call out your area code yes let me put
myself on and then we can start hearing
from some folks and seeing what else
what else is going on very very exciting
night we are here okay let's just see
what's on people's minds why don't we go
first to our caller from the 484 area
code caller from 484 what's going on did
you vote please tell me you did I did
vote yeah okay but I voted who's this
what's going on the 11th Congressional
District of Pennsylvania I was doing a
little bit of research I suggest King
here versus mark I'm sure you've been
taking note of jesting so smokers taken
like about a million dollars there
abouts in bribes from the oil and gas
industry I mean I listened to your show
pretty frequently so obviously a
well-informed
I'm chemist by trade so my number one
issue is global warming and I mean you
know it's kind of fallen by the wayside
with concerns about immigration and
health care and guns and obviously these
are super impactful issues but
I mean this I don't think people really
understand you tell me David do people
do you need to be in the know to be
worried about this issue why is it
fallen by the wayside you shouldn't need
to be the problem is that there has been
a concerted effort from the right to
make just science and facts knowable
facts controversial and political the
sort of that there has been an epistemic
indifference to the truth we're now even
truth is not a winning political
platform so yeah I think this is a big
problem and we've been talking about how
we how do you convince people who don't
care about facts and who fundamentally
don't value the telling of truth by our
elected officials that they are being
misled on the issue of climate change or
on any other issue I don't know the
answer but it's very very ugly it's not
it's not a good thing that's going on
and I appreciate the call and I hope
your election there goes goes your way
let's see who's calling us from the 7:01
area code caller from 701 go ahead oh hi
David yes
hey I've goin good Johnny from Fargo
North Dakota um I just got back from the
polling place in my district you know
Heidi Heitkamp and it's a considered to
be the key race in the Senate as far as
which party ends up taking it um a lot
of cautious optimism I mean for my part
I saw a lot of younger people at the
polling place I felt like that gave me
some hope but I'm still not quite sure
what to expect by the time results come
in yes well I don't know either I'm
trying to pull those up right now even
though the New York Times results page
must be getting slammed because it's now
not loading that is an interesting race
and I tend to agree with you we might
have to go back to that doesn't seem to
be loading right now I tend to agree
with you that that is going to be a race
that's interesting for a couple
different reasons one it'll be
interesting to see you know Heitkamp had
to be very careful in terms of her her
her commentary on the Brett Kavanaugh
situation because there was risk there
either way
so that will be interesting to see how
that shakes out and it also may be sort
of a flagship or indicator indicator
race for sure but yeah I mean I don't
know that we can deduce that much from
exactly what went on at your polling
place like I went to a polling place
here in Boston that quite frankly was
dead but that doesn't necessarily tell
us too much so we'll be watching
together it sounds like yeah and and the
big thing too with North Dakota and why
it's such a toss-up is everything
outside the Red River Valley which is
basically the east quarter of the state
is very much Trump country yes well we
just got hit with snowstorms so who
knows what that'll affect things
all right good we'll glad we got in the
rural area there that always can even
snow can impact the results that's for
sure we know that well in the rural area
that really appreciated let's take one
more call and then we're gonna get into
some other results that are coming in
five one three area code caller from the
five one three area code go ahead hey
David it's James from Cincinnati a big
fan of your show thanks Sam I was
curious what this talk about the voter
suppression in Georgia
I mean Ohio but are you aware of any
like published data that gets put out
every year about showing how many actual
machines are in each location cuz I
would love to see a breakdown of you
know to see how many machines are
actually at like the traditionally black
neighborhood voting places versus the
white ones because my white area had
plenty of machines but then I hear
stories about Georgia places
predominantly urban areas and why I
could be wrong but I hear they have like
one machine I was running to you are you
aware of any kind of data they could
published well the thing is they're not
aware of that data specifically but the
important thing with data like that
anyway is that you need to know really
voting machines per capita right because
if you have twice as many voting
machines but three times as many people
the fact that there's more voting
machines doesn't really account for the
fact that the people are kind of being
underserved that would be interesting to
look at but I don't have that data I've
not seen that data okay all right no
problem great to hear from you let's see
who's calling from six one two call her
from six one two I know that area code
and I don't remember where it is where
is six one two Minnesota
okay go ahead
calling I was gonna say I've recently
been set up with the Democrats
constantly and blatantly running away
from their base I think when I was
wondering if you um mostly in like the
2016 election I think a lot of people
were firmly behind Bernie Sanders and
they did a lot of things to kind of get
out of that okay but so are you saying
that on the issues the Democratic Party
has abandoned the base or you're saying
that you're just talking about their
primary in 2016 okay
they were super super hesitant with you
know it seems like legalizing marijuana
and all of these issues I couldn't name
right now for you but it seems that they
just pull away towards a more
establishment
men type of view on it okay so wondering
if I'm abandoning that based on certain
issues like this maybe makes it easier
for progressives to kind of let them
know it it's possible but if they also
control the bully pulpit and can keep
those progressives from actually getting
any traction
then the answer would be no right so yes
on the issues it should and I'm gonna
it's very very loud in the background
I'm gonna let you go and and we'll
finish talking about this off just
without you on the phone because it's
getting very loud there yeah I mean
listen on the one hand you would think
that as the population continues to move
left which the US population has on just
about every issue abortion polling on
abortion polling on gun safety polling
on whether the government has some basic
duty to provide some level of health
care to everybody regardless of ability
to pay the country has moved to the left
and yet our representation in many ways
has not and we can say that it's because
of the how
campaigns are funded and and the
inability to break that status quo we
can say that it's the power of
incumbency there's a lot of different
ways to sort of approach it but this is
a real issue and ultimately I think that
we are going to really have progressive
ideas represented in the House and
Senate to the degree that they exist in
the general population you are going to
need to change fix
I call it campaign finance and probably
put in place some different kind of
voting system I don't I just don't see
any way any way around it whatsoever
I would love to be able to get here we
go we've got the results back so let's
see how we're doing now we have now of
the 435 House seats up for re-election
all of them we have nine Democrat wins
and ten Republican wins nine and ten
Democrats need plus twenty five in order
to take over control and the data
continues to come in there and we will
be following it let's take a look at the
Senate in the Senate we are now starting
to get data in other places we have West
Virginia data let me make sure this is
visible where Joe Manchin with under one
percent reporting arguably the most
conservative Democrat in the Senate
winning with a close to two-to-one
margin but it is extraordinarily early
let's go back to Florida which is an
interesting one where Bill Nelson now
now we're talking about numbers in
Florida let's take a closer look here so
the upside in Florida is that with a
fifth of the vote in 22 percent
reporting in Florida bill Nelson is up
by about a hundred and four hundred and
three and a half thousand votes 21%
reporting now what we do need to look at
is how much of these lower three
counties are in and this is I listened
with peace and love at 7:22 p.m. on
Election Day 2016 based on the Florida
data
I knew that Trump was going to win we
have different data from Florida right
now and if you ask me what I think given
that at 7:52 p.m. Eastern Time and I see
that bill Nelson's ahead by over a
hundred thousand votes
with only initial results from
miami-dade only one of 577 precincts
reporting in Broward County and only
about what is that two and a half
percent of Palm Beach County precincts
reporting which are going to inevitably
invariably go for Bill Nelson this is
good data for bill Nelson in Florida and
this is generally good data for
Democrats okay you disagree let me know
in a super chat and I'll get to those
super chats in a second so this is good
that's good to see already talked about
Bernie winning in Vermont Indiana the
numbers are not looking good for Joe
Donnelly so this was opposite Florida as
a sort of flagship indicator of where
tonight was going to go we had a sense
that if Joe Donnelly could do really
well in Indiana that would be a good
sign for Democrats he's not doing well
we now have a fifth of the votes counted
and he is down by almost 20 points now
let's take a look you have Indianapolis
okay so only a percent or two of
Indianapolis is in that will be useful
to Joe Donnelly because that is
presumably going to be a place that is
more favorable to him Fort Wayne is
another place and only initial results
there so that's all good we have nothing
in Evansville in Vanderburgh County that
could be a factor but the numbers aren't
great in Indiana right now and just
because we are getting better and better
numbers for Bill Nelson in Florida who
now has increased the lead to a hundred
and 18,000 votes
sorry I'm realized I realize I'm
covering that 118 thousand votes with 24
percent reporting let's go over to the
governor's races and see how Florida is
looking for Andrew Gilliam which is very
exciting
Andrew Gilliam now has built a lead of
90,000 votes with 20% reporting and
again we have very little of the big
blue three Palm Beach Broward and
miami-dade so far so that's a good thing
that is that is a very very good thing
let me do a couple Super chats because I
know they're coming
and by the way I do want to mention to
everybody who's on our stream we have
had a identified let me I'm gonna get
the super chance in a second before I do
that I identified months ago that it was
time to put everything behind the 2018
midterms I've been refusing to talk
about 2020 even though there's a
clamoring for it and by the way I will
have very interesting information for
you about 2020 later this week or early
next week including an interview in
person with one of the most progressive
members of Congress coming up this week
in person here in Boston very exciting
stuff anyway
not to get sidetracked I identified that
everything needs to be about the 2018
midterms I identified that we need to be
supporting progressive media so I
created a coupon code that saves anybody
that wants at 40% off of their
memberships at david pakman.com slash
membership that coupon code is vote soon
18 that coupon code is done at midnight
tonight why because it wouldn't make
sense after tonight the inter the the
voting will be over so if you value the
David Pakman show I'm not gonna do this
all night but please use that coupon
code vote soon 18 on our website for
membership it'll save you 40% I will
thank you and along those lines I do
want to say thanks to Thomas Kitts who
just signed up and Nora arrant who just
signed up and Chris Leavitt all of whom
oh and Diane glaze glaze nur glaze nur
who just signed up I will be thanking
people all night and if you make a
pledge on patreon at patreon.com slash
david pakman show i will also be
thanking you all night let's get to some
of the super chats now including a $200
super chat which came in which I will
get to in order if I may uh okay Ivan
Escalante Ivan Escalante says what does
Ivan Escalante say your thoughts on bado
my thoughts are I think he's great and I
think he's got an uphill battle and we
will know will we know at 8:00 or 9:00
p.m. Eastern about early results there
we might know very soon jerem be says
what's your position on question one in
Massachusetts I
opted not to vote on question one in
Massachusetts it's very interesting that
you asked me that it's a question here
in Massachusetts a ballot initiative
related to putting limits on the number
of patients that can be assigned to
nurses in hospitals and I found very
completely compelling arguments on both
sides and on these I really take these
very seriously and if I'm not sure that
I'm voting the right way I opted to
leave it blank so I voted YES on two in
Massachusetts
I voted YES on three in Massachusetts
but I am NOT I did not vote on question
one and I don't know what the results
are going to be the lone chemist for
1999 in your opinion what election
tonight is the most important or
indicative of the current political
landscape of the country also I have a
video s a YouTube channel police shout
me out
keep up the superb commentary I just
don't think that there's one race it's
very easy to sort of point to some of
these flagship races like we've been
talking about you know we've been
looking at at Florida here for
gubernatorial and we've been looking at
it for Senate I think that there are
races so like let's take Texas for
example Texas is an important race if
Ted Cruz loses right if Ted Cruz wins
it's not that important what happens in
Texas cuz that's what should happen the
incumbent Republican senator should win
in Texas so I think that there's no
right answer the question is which ones
are important if Republicans win and
which ones are important if if Democrats
win and Texas is one that's important if
Democrats when Jenny kiss'd says Porter
followed thisis a lagoon in Espanola no
that's wrong what you mean is put
forward DC I you go the CIO in Espanola
she just wants me to say something in
Spanish which I just did master T sends
a $2 super chat J watt sends a $10 super
chat huge fan from Oregon you're the
best David I listen to every clip on
YouTube every day while I work
thank you for your show and shout out to
Pat Thank You Wiesn as sends a 200
dollar super chat the high-water mark
for the evening Wiesn as thank you let's
see should I even wonder if I can even
switch to
so people can see what I'm looking at
here yeah here we go so now you can
actually see the Super chats so I'm on
this one but from Wiesn as Wiesn as says
I'm a huge fan from Oregon another I
love the show you've mentioned many of
my subreddits in the past speakeasy
dictionary nationalizing banks etc in
the future can you comment on a
subreddit post you talk about so we
don't miss your reactions if we miss a
particular segment I have reason as I
love you for the donation I have no idea
what you're talking about
I mentioned your sub reddits I think you
mean I've mentioned your reddit posts
I've mentioned your reddit posts in the
past fair enough
can I comment on posts I talked about so
I don't miss so you don't miss me
talking about them yeah I will make an
effort to do that I will make an effort
to do that gram carpenter for $5 hey
David you're one of the best progressive
voices and alternative media loved your
takedown of Jesse Lee Peterson I have a
good story for you I was walking
downtown Boston today I had just gone to
the post office I was on the phone with
our payroll company I was doing all
sorts of stuff and all of a sudden I
hear someone go Pac Man and I as I was
walking and I turn around and it's a guy
who looks at me and he says Jesse Lee
owned you and I couldn't tell if the guy
was joking or if he was telling the
truth and he thought that Jesse Lee
Peterson owned me I don't know which one
it was but it was scary but fortunately
he didn't beat me up Paul says for $5.00
David do you think recreational
marijuana will happen in North Dakota
early numbers look promising we also
need the house to turn blue and we can
stop Trump I have no idea about
recreational marijuana in North Dakota I
haven't I haven't followed that one I
hope it does happen I think it should I
think that's the right vote Terry James
for $5.00 a similar question as before
but should Democrats try to turn Florida
blue absolutely absolutely Florida is
already a state that sometimes goes blue
right so why why wouldn't Democrats say
let's push that to be reliably blue
let's get a Democratic governor let's
get a democratic
senator in that would all be fantastic
of course Florida should be a top
priority
Brian Connor for $2 David is the real
great white hope amazing
I'm a Hispanic Jew immigrant from
Argentina when it's convenient to play
that otherwise I guess I'm just a white
guy James Allen for $10 love the show
thanks for taking my call earlier from
the five one three area code David is
the real alpha male
lol people asking about the coupon code
by the way coupon code is vote soon 18
okay vote soon 18 lets you get a david
pakman show membership for three dollars
and sixty cents a month you get all the
stuff every you get a hundred percent of
the benefits but you get a 40% discount
okay and on that note I want to get to
some other results that we have coming
in we will let these it's very clear
that these are being updated now with 8
p.m. results so in the meantime let me
say thanks to Pete Mercado who has
signed up with the 40% discount let me
say thanks to allod Gary Yanni who is
now a member
Henrietta Lee is a new member hi to is a
new member I already mentioned Nora
okay many new members vote soon 18 you
save 40 percent you keep the discount
for as long as you want ww join
pakman.com it expires at midnight
because then it's no more vote soon 18
it's just it's over so let's see what
we've got we have early numbers from
massachusetts i'm gonna guess that
elizabeth warren is doing well in
massachusetts and well with 0% reporting
she has won so i think that tells us
about everything we need to know i
apologize i keep covering the results
everything we need to know about
elizabeth warren race connecticut
Christopher Murphy the incumbent
Democrat 0% reporting he has won because
it clearly it is very very lopsided
Delaware Senator Carper has won with 0%
reporting it is not even close Maryland
Ben Cardin has won re-election with 0%
reporting and as I mentioned before in
Virginia
Kaine has also won West Virginia still
under 1% reporting but joe Manchin is
ahead let's just check in with floor man
floor
Florida's very very interesting today
isn't it with 40 percent reporting Bill
Nelson has increased his lead to 114
thousand votes I believe if I'm doing
the math somewhat correctly 1 112 and to
114 we still have in Palm Beach County
under 5 percent of precincts reporting
in Broward County we have about a third
of precincts reporting and Bill Nelson
is up 7 370 to 30 and in miami-dade
County now with half reporting 6044 bill
Nelson so the key now is if the lead
doesn't grow as these three counties
come in that could mean that as the
Florida Panhandle comes though so the
Florida Panhandle is on Central Time
that's why we have no data here so far
and they closed an hour later and it's
very conservative up there in fact
Pensacola which county is that Escambia
County is where Pensacola is that's
where our friends at Levin Papantonio
law firm are it's it's it's pretty
conservative in all that area so the
point that I'm trying to make is even
though the population is much higher in
these key 3 counties you got to get a
big lead there before the rest closes
because otherwise you can be you can be
in trouble and let's check in on Florida
over on the governor side and absolutely
no surprise here in Massachusetts
Charlie Baker with 0% reporting has one
so that gets that gets Republicans to
eight eight to seven in terms of
governor's not a surprise at all very
popular guy and you know what here's
something I've been thinking about the
fact that Republicans seem so easily
able to become governors in the very
blue state of Massachusetts we could say
is concerning we can analyze a number of
ways the fact that when you have a
moderate Republican governor who is
forced to work with a very left
legislature in Massachusetts and
for the most part does okay right I
didn't vote for the guy but he's doing
okay
to me it signals that Massachusetts
voters are not simply ideologically
voting for the Democrat merely because
they are Democrats and there's a
Democrat on the ballot that actually for
me is sort of a it's not that I like
seeing Republicans win but it's kind of
a positive thing in a sense for the sort
of way that people in Massachusetts vote
let's look in Florida in Florida now we
have see if I can get this framed
properly in Florida we now have a lead
for Andrew Gilliam of 183 thousand votes
roughly with no that's wrong that's
completely wrong it's eighty-three
thousand votes with 43 percent reporting
Andrew Gilliam is up and this is just a
very very exciting race same analysis
applies where you've got to do well in
these three counties because when the
Panhandle closes that will give a boost
to the Republican so that is a that's a
big thing that is a big thing and we are
gonna continue to track that one eight
to seven in terms of governor's 3042 for
Democrats and Republicans in the Senate
we do have some good blue states closing
and that is helping and over in the
house 19 to 16 Democrats over
Republicans of course every single seat
is up here and we will continue to track
that let's see what they're saying about
Massachusetts by associates though you
have a hole for Republican it's Charlie
Baker very popular governor in the stick
but it's certainly setting it up even
more dramatically is Democrats at some
point have to get their arms around and
define what medicare-for-all means for
every Democrat it means something
different and whoever the Democratic
nominee is is going to have to really
clearly outline that and for right now I
think that is fine that we don't have an
answer but it's going to be more
challenging going forward we're going to
come back to all of this as the night
goes on all right somehow it was really
interesting House races because they've
shaken up the map yeah all right well so
anyway PBS is doing a fine job let's
what's going on over on NBC in Delaware
Tom Carper also the incumbent and he is
headed back to the United States Senate
and in the Maryland Senate race Ben
Cardin the incumbent will be returning
we project he wins also Pennsylvania
Senate to a race Bob Casey Lou Barletta
yeah incumbent Democrat Bob Casey will
go on to win tonight all right and let's
talk about Rhode Island Sheldon
Whitehouse all right so we'll get caught
up on all of these as soon as the map
gets updated I'm not seeing that
Republican or the Democratic win no no
they are updating it okay so they're
they're continuing to update Sheldon
Whitehouse is one there okay so things
no big surprises so far we're really
just kind of watching watching races
let's get to a couple of other super
chats as they come in here let's see if
I can put those up for us yes I can
let's take a look here
Muhammad Naz me bin Somali with a five
British pound super chat says my country
Malaysia kicked out the ruling party of
61 years thanks to young voters I
followed that story hope the same
dynamics apply tonight I hope so
Mohammed let's see
Quinn Lovato for $4.99 what do you think
about the younger generations staring
turn starting to turn Republican I think
they mean with the rise of people like
Ben Shapiro I I have not actually seen
any data that tells me that young people
are turning Republican in any way that
would be significant at this time I just
I just don't see that that's backed up
by the facts John Miller for $2 says
David Pakman show better than mainstream
well right clicks out of out of nowhere
better than mainstream media thank you I
appreciate that
and Alma guest for 5 euro says hey dude
watching from Ireland hope that all goes
well drank too much whiskey think I
might get sick I was actually thinking
of getting myself a fur net during an
upcoming break if I have any available
in the studio we we keep some bottles in
the studio and I'm gonna see if I but
maybe I should wait to to celebrate
until we actually have something to
celebrate right because right now it's
it's still very very early appreciate
the super chats keeping
in the house Democrats and Republicans
both gaining a couple of seats 22 for
Democrats 18 for Republicans of course
you need to 18 for control and we are
going to continue following that as this
district North Carolina's first District
goes to the incumbent Butterfield
I don't know Butterfield I don't know if
Butterfield is congressman or
congresswoman see if we zoom in on that
one
GK Butterfield I don't know who that is
let's look at the full results still not
clear who Butterfield is hmm
Butterfield Butterfield where is that
here not seeing it but we are starting
to get out of other interesting data
let's take a look just for kicks at the
Massachusetts ballot questions if we can
cuz I am curious how those went and how
I based on how I voted let's close out
some of this stuff here ballot questions
in Massachusetts Charlie Baker as I
mentioned has one oh we have no data yet
okay so yeah ballot these polls just
closed minutes ago in Massachusetts so
we don't yet have any data there 22 to
18 in the house 30 42 in the Senate and
I would guess we still have seven to
eight 7 to 8 for governors and we are
going to be following all of those for
the evening a couple of other do I want
to get to a couple of other super chats
here yes I do
who was it so Terry James says do you
think the country will go in a leftward
shift when Millennials replace baby move
baby boomers as a major voting bloc in
general when an older voting group dies
out and is replaced by a younger voting
group that does move the country to the
left it's not because individuals become
more conservative as they get older it's
because each subsequently younger
generation tends to be to the left of
the previous one waiting to fade asks
which website are you looking at yeah so
this is the New York Times live election
results and they're pretty good I like
them so that's what I've been looking at
and Marco Aguada asks debated an old
dude in the gym sauna with your talking
points he was not happy he scared the
Democrats are coming for his Social
Security and Marco Perez says love you
David thoughts on Kevin de Leon from
California yeah I'm a fan let's see if
we can take a look at so we got to go
over to let's find that that's kind of
an interesting race there I don't know
exactly where that is located
see if I can just go into California
bigger picture oh no now the New York
Times wants me to sign in that's not
good we are gonna have to boy I'm gonna
have to open up an in-car how
embarrassing I'm gonna have to open up
an incognito browser or something when
we when we go to a break that's that's
the the New York Times website big fan
of of Kevin de Leon and I I don't even
know what's happening here we are having
all of a sudden nothing seems to be
working right but we have oh boy things
have just not gotten so good in Florida
the horsemen of Donald Trump is
anxiously waiting as he exited today
from the polls he said already worked
across the aisle with rick scott on
hurricane recovery efforts I'm sure that
I can do it with President Trump if and
when it comes to that once I'm governor
stuff alright Ally vitaliy in Naples
Florida Ali thank you I know you have
got a long night ahead all right I want
to talk more about the president because
this guy has been on a media blitz he
held over 30 rallies in the two months
since Labor Day to motivate his base
it's his favorite thing to do an exit
poll okay so Justin I'm we're getting
conflicting information in their vote
for the house what is going on we're
getting conflicting information about
what's going on in Florida we are almost
simultaneously getting information
saying it's going really well for
gilliam to it's not going so well for
Gilliam so we need to figure out what
exactly is going on there and the
numbers by the way not very good for
Phil Bredesen in Tennessee not good at
all let's see what's happening
recorder here in Orange County careful
evoke the stairs here has said that this
is the highest turnout he has ever seen
in a midterm election and he's 15 years
on the job the line continues to stretch
down here there are a 200 thousand
people that are expected to vote in
person hundreds of thousands of absentee
ballots are expected to be tabulated
after this day and look there's an
entire another line all the way down
that way you guys back to you all right
people are lined up to vote fascinating
let's go to the phone 607 eight-30 47 50
let's go to Carlo from 804 who's been
holding for a half hour apologies for
that caller from 804 what's going on hey
man why you're on the line right now
hey my name is Berlin from Virginia I'm
actually a libertarian a huge fan of
your show and you doing a job thank you
and I noted first time today well I
voted before but first time voting
Democrat my district wasn't that
interesting because Bobby Scott is
running unelected unopposed and Tim
Kaine was kind of a shoo-in for Virginia
but the the district that I think is
very interesting is the second race with
Abigail Spann burger and David brat
mm-hmm that that's my actually my
hometown district and that's gone to the
GOP for about the last 50 years and it's
kind of a toss-up right now yes well
it's it's too early to know exactly
what's going to happen there but I
appreciate the call and we'll be
watching that one along with many many
others let's see we've got I believe
this is it was hard to hear his name
last time you called is this jynson from
New Jersey yes Dave did I get that right
Jameson well we have Colorado anything I
have a question so should Democrats take
back the house maybe even Senate he
would Trump turn volatile and desperate
and do something more crazy do you see a
scenario like that happening where he
like a wounded animal backed into a
corner what if
do you see a scenario where he'll be
even more I do I do and I think I mean
at minimum there will be allegations of
voting irregularities in favor of
Democrats that's that's like a given
that's not even we don't even have to
talk about that then the real question
is is he going to amp up the sort of a
did the the the sort of catalyzing of
actual violence in the real world that's
kind of the question but at minimum he
will he will question the results for
sure okay all right I just wanted to see
your thoughts on that because I think
we're gonna win on like pass predictions
earlier but I do I am worried about
scenario where you start turning to the
desperation and blames this blame that
starts doing irrational behavior well
even more irrational behavior yeah well
I heard animals often become erratic so
I think your concern is completely and
utterly reasonable for sure thanks for
the call Jensen appreciate it
let's see who is there from the 786 area
code I know you've been holding a while
what's going on I'm calling from Miami
all right Shawn what's going on I'm uh
I'm a Venezuelan American citizen okay I
moved here three years ago so I've voted
both there and here yes today was the
first time I voted in person and I voted
about it was a kind of a nicer suburb
part of Miami
okay it was 4:30 so kind of late but the
main difference that I saw is that there
was you know not that many people there
yeah oh I wondered for that normal I
don't think I don't think we can judge
anything from how busy any one precinct
is at any one time yeah I just don't
think it tells us anything they just
know what I expected because voting over
there at least a few the last times I
did it was a two three-hour ordeal
yeah with lines around the block and I'm
sure because you know it's a very
inefficiently run country but I did
expect to see
you know like I barely waited yeah no I
was uh there was one person in front of
me when I went to vote and there were
two people in front of me to check out
and put their ballots in the machines
and I was sort of surprised but I can't
you we can't read into it we're just
gonna have to wait and see what the
results are
yeah yeah all right thank you so much
for the call
I very much appreciate it let's check in
with one other person at the 3-5-2 area
code then I've got to do new member
thank-yous and new patron thank-yous and
a whole bunch of stuff but three five
two go ahead
hey this mean that's you amazing this is
Quinn was from Orlando Florida just
saying hi I was actually speaking I
wanted to say something about what you
said earlier about like people
understanding like what actually is true
and understanding data and how like they
can interpret that into their like
voting patterns again uh well I mean
this can you be a little more specific
in terms of how you want me to address
that well basically I was just wanting
to I live basically in a very Republican
very hardcore conservative family and
for me I've noticed that a lot of people
obviously vote with what they feel and
they take anecdote over data by 200
percent of the time so it's really
difficult to get people to to persuade
people who are like that yeah on that
here's the real problem once people are
at voting age if they still don't have
any sense of how to do critical thinking
and how to analyze the basis of their
beliefs and sort of basic concepts like
anecdotal evidence versus actual
representative data you're you're
already kind of losing because now
you've got to explain all this stuff to
them and make it part of their because
the important thing is if you you need
to have as a foundation a process for
critically examining assertions that are
made out in the world and how you come
to conclusions and your own beliefs and
if you
first come up with opinions about stuff
and then someone tries to teach you the
methods for evaluating those opinion
it's it's happening backwards if that
makes sense so it's just it's it's an an
overwhelming uphill battle yeah
absolutely
well I appreciate you taking my call
thank you appreciate appreciate you
calling in let me take just one more
call because there is one other person
who's been waiting a half hour on the
five seven zero area code what's going
on five seven zero that's you hey my
question is you know how is it how how
important is it you know at time to
times at time just set aside politics
then get out there like like so you had
an earlier caller about global warming
how important is it just to let go out
there and and a tree actually we did a
story we're doing a story this week on
the bonus show about like six things
that you can just start doing right away
and planting trees I mean if you have a
place to plant the tree that's great but
things things like making sure you're
not throwing away any food making sure
you're thinking about your heat and air
conditioning usage there are things we
can just do and of course it kind of
feels like nothing's gonna happen if
it's only you doing it and I totally
understand that but I completely agree
with you that we should be political
activists at the same time that we are
actually living the values we espouse
because if everybody did that then the
need for activism would go down somewhat
because we'd have so many people just
doing the stuff if that makes sense
and how exactly then do you weigh when
it's more important to take these small
actions and then once more important to
like they make a comment in the federal
registrar I don't think it's one or the
other I mean we all live lives in the
world so while you're doing that you
should be living your values and doing
the stuff if your values are that you
want to help with reforestation and tree
planting then you do that and you also
do political activism I just don't think
it's one or the other
like I'm regularly doing the activism I
do on the show but I'm still making
conscious decisions in my life about
purchasing decisions heating throwing
food away you know all that all that
sort of stuff I think we just do it all
at the same time
I bomb let's say I have like a limited
amount of time though what I'm saying
what I'm things are following you may or
may not have time for activism but
almost everyone has decisions that they
can make every day about whether they
are going to drive or ride their bike or
whether they're gonna think carefully
about whether they should really get a
tour for bananas because you're gonna
throw out four of them because you never
eat eight bananas and a Wii or whatever
right so that's just like everybody does
that stuff and then maybe you have time
for activism or you don't but I don't
think making good decisions day to day
takes away your ability to be an
activist either you've got time for that
or you don't but you still got to make
decisions every day I will take that to
heart thank you David all right thank
you appreciate the call
I'm leaving the phone lines open I'm
just not going to take any more calls
right this second because I've got a
whole bunch of other stuff to catch up
on I need to say thanks to a bunch of
people who have signed up at wwlp.com
with the coupon code that ends today if
you want to support progressive
independent media if you watched an ad
before the stream started thank you
we probably made a fifth of a penny off
of that and that adds up I'm not saying
that as a joke I'm really not saying
that as a joke that adds up but if you
have the capacity to do a little more
you can use the coupon code vote soon 18
which expires at midnight tonight it's
been around for months expires tonight
because the election is over you can go
to WWE on Comm you get the bonus show
the commercial free audio feed the
commercial free video feed the feeling
that you're doing something really good
and I want to thank Stewart's is it
Stewart Schmidt I believe it is your
name came through weirdly on membership
Dana Corbin has signed up for membership
Adam Perkins is a new member anna Botti
or Beatty is a new member Joshua Stahl
is a new member
Connor Lydon is a new member and Pete
Mercado I think was the last one from
the last batch that I mentioned thank
you and you don't have to do this
membership thing if you
go to patreon.com make a quick pledge of
as little as a dollar a month to support
the work that we do you can do that as
well that's also very very much
appreciated and I would even argue it's
encouraged appreciated and encouraged
and you will also get a thank you from
me that's for sure I can assure you that
no doubt whatsoever let's see what's
going on with results and then we are
gonna dip into coverage from PBS for a
few minutes and then we've got more
super chats I want to hear from people
by the way I mentioned this earlier and
I'm still up for doing it I don't know
exactly how I would do it but on skype I
can call any phone number and we can all
hear it so if you know how I might be
able to call in to some other shows that
are streaming progressive shows maybe
even our friends like his Sam live right
now is Sam cedar live and does he have a
call-in number maybe I could call in on
Sam's show is Kyle kolinsky streaming if
he is and he's taking calls in some way
I don't know if he's doing that let me
know via super chat how I could call
into his show because that could be an
interesting thing see what other people
are doing in the house 27 to 28
Democrats have secured 27 seats and
Republicans have secured 28 seats and it
is still very very early over in the
Senate 31 to 42 31 to 42 I already
mentioned some of these races Tim Kaine
in Virginia and Elizabeth Warren in
Massachusetts and Christopher Murphy and
Sheldon Whitehouse in Connecticut and
Rhode Island respectively sherrod Brown
in Ohio they've they've won their races
already we have a couple of races that
have now turned against us one of those
is in Florida Florida now with 70%
reporting and as you can see here boom
the Panhandle has come in and it is red
as far as the eye can see Rick Scott has
taken over the lead there and now leads
by 11,000 votes now it still remains
that these three counties have not yet
given us that many that much of their
results and they are very very high
population we still have a third of
miami-dade County to go we have about
half of Brad
Howard County ready to go still to go
and we have more than half of Palm Beach
County still to go so we've got to watch
that but it didn't it didn't go well in
the last 10 minutes that's unfortunate
early numbers in Texas we have with one
percent reporting challenger bado
or Roark ahead of Ted Cruz it just
doesn't mean anything right now Travis
County though Austin which I assume will
go blue no reporting so far Dallas one
precinct two to one in favor of beta or
Roark extraordinarily early we cannot
deduce anything from these early results
so far and we are starting to see these
colors why is it what's Mississippi Oh
Mississippi special election I see I was
wondering
there was another Mississippi in the
ocean which is odd very very odd we're
starting to see some color sort of
filled in there and then over on the
gubernatorial side we have also seen
Andrew gillum's lead evaporate in
Florida very very unfortunate but again
we just had the Panhandle come in and we
are still slowly getting results in from
these big three counties but as of right
now Ron DeSantis has taken a lead over
Andrew Gilliam by just under 40,000
votes and nobody likes to see that other
than the obvious people that want to see
exactly that okay I think what was that
noise I think that was a us getting did
we just get disconnected from hmm
I got disconnected from my own phones
phone system interesting Lee enough but
people can keep calling in and will will
get reconnected and take some more calls
briefly
thanks to Corvis who is a new $5 a month
patron thank you very very much let's
dip in to the PBS news hour coverage
briefly and then we will come back with
more results in just five minutes let's
take a listen to this and see see what
exactly is going on here
some are most vulnerable and I think
we're still sometimes left to be counted
alcohol to call us to Bella has been
closed all the time I think it's
Mother's Day right now we feel good
about where we are we just gotta keep
fighting and again we were fighting a
lot of perception going in I think this
is this is a really good night so far
I've got a long way to go but so far
especially right here in Georgia would
feel good congressman how much
difference in all this as president
Trump made do you think in his
campaigning for Republicans I think
President Trump is done well I think
what is forgotten many times in
specially inside the beltway is for
those who just watch the president they
just believe that he can do nothing
right but when he goes into districts
even districts that are closed
there are fifteen twenty thirty percent
of the Republican base that is very much
behind this president even in districts
it or not that was maybe way for Hillary
Clinton in that face each time he turns
that face out but he also makes the
stark contrast especially hearings or
them any place in the governor's races
in the Senate races and even so house is
it just the choice on the future do you
want a future that it looked like the
Obama administration or you go on the
futures looks like the talk last 24 24
months but which it has been prosperous
and moving forward on the economy and
even a lot of the exit polls are saying
the economy is doing very well I think
that's been the unseen this part in the
debate going up to the collection well
we're certainly seeing some evidence at
this point this evening that president
Trump's sick campaigning has made a
difference congressman Doug Collins who
is the vice chair of the National
Republican Congressional Committee
joining us from Athens Georgia
congressman thank you very much thanks
for driving goodnight and now we want to
turn to our colleagues amnon of Oz and
Lisa deja our dad they've been looking
at some of these races we've been
talking about digging into the data what
they mean for the bigger picture Amna a
Judy that's right well to the
congressman's point and as we've heard
over the course of the night over the
course of the last several weeks
president Trump has loomed large in
several of these contests we want to
take a closer look to see how that could
affect some key races on the ground if
you bring up that Senate map Lisa walk
us through what we are looking at here
and what you're looking now it's about
half past eight on the East Coast what
matters right now okay so there are 35
states have voted for US senator today
and those are all the states as you see
marked in gray blue red and of course
the ones that are being defended by
Democrats those are in
these are not just any democratic states
these are the ones that are vulnerable
these are the competitive states in blue
and red what's notable especially see
all these blue states I'm gonna Florida
down there these with the exception of
New Jersey all of these are states that
President Obama won and that is why
Democrats have been so worried about the
Senate and why it's been so difficult
for them to expect to take over the
Senate from Republicans this year
because of all the Trump wins in 2016 in
these states that have Democratic
senators so three of those states polls
have closed and right that you're
looking very very closely out let's tick
through these very quickly and can give
us a sense of what we're looking at here
Indiana where the incumbent Democrat Joe
Donnelly is being challenged here what
are we seeing so far right
Democrats really like this race for a
couple of reasons Joe Donnelly is well
known he's a hard-working campaigner and
also there's a libertarian candidate in
this race I know you hosted a debate
here she had a strong presence in that
debate they were hoping she could be a
helpful force for Joe Donnelly who
actually advertised for her at one point
but what we see in these early results
is that Mike Braun the Republican is way
ahead and I want to look at these three
states in the context of what Amy
brought up earlier states were the
president won by double digits or single
digits this is a state where President
Trump won by 19 points very very good
exciting that that's what Donald Trump
did let's take a look at some more
election results because the map is
increasingly getting filled in we have
super chats we have all sorts of stuff
going on eight to nine eight to nine
when it comes to governors let's get an
update on the house which according to
the New York Times is 28 to 33 28 to 33
in the house in favor of Republicans and
in the Senate 31 to 42 nothing new there
so far okay so I got some super chats
from people giving me different shows
that we could call and check in with let
me first just go through some of these
super chats and see what's on people's
minds
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh where did we leave
off
Theo phob asks if Dems win the House of
Representatives Republican Senate what
can Democrats do to trump investigations
prevent more abortive tax
reform as they like to call it or tax
plans there's actually and I'm gonna
talk about that actually with a sitting
progressive congressman later this week
it's a really important question bill
Overson asks curious on your thoughts on
why most of the country is stuck with
waiting in lines to go to a polling
place here in Washington State it's all
mail-in ballots yeah what we're so
behind I mean it's just embarrassing and
part of it is that the election systems
part of maintaining the status quo with
election systems is what allows them to
be manipulated and used to suppress the
vote so that's that's part of it
unfortunately Connor Lydon sends a
dollar with no comment or question thank
you
kurutsu sends 20 Mexican pesos slow down
David you always rush too much calls
okay that's that's fair I feel like at
this point I've developed a little bit
of a sense of when the audience starts
to glaze over so I and I may be wrong
and if I am I will spend more time on
each call I fart magic sends a two
dollar super chat peace and love
ingrid p $2 cleo vinyl 22 says call kyle
or the young turks jeremy says I'm
surrounded by conservatives and
inundated with small smug lapdogs like
ben shapiro steven crowder dave rubin
thanks for making me feel less depressed
with your thoughtful commentary my
pleasure
je d lrc says oh what Sam's phone number
is let's try to call Sam cedar then
let's see if we can get on six for six
uh-huh two five seven thirty nine twenty
six four six two five seven thirty nine
twenty see what happens let's see oh
right so plus one I have to tell Skype
let's take us see what happens thank you
for calling into the majority report Sam
we'll be with you shortly that plays a
role in places like Florida like could
we actually be winning the legislators
by not winning the governorship meaning
if we just didn't put the money into the
governor's it's wonder that time I mean
tell not hold much more money but it
sexing down-ballot so that's where they
went is the legislature they are
basically saying lay low
in certain areas and be I mean maybe I
don't know
yeah a Josh what's your sense well I
also think that if you're just talking
about money I think it's not necessarily
a zero-sum game right it's going on Sam
like Andrew Gilliam actually you know
makes the plane feel bigger right it's
not just sort of a set pot of national
money that gets distributed it's not
just a certain amount of grassroots
fundraising that that's gets solicited
by email lists right it you know okay I
don't know if this will work I don't
know if he's even listening to his over
looking at his phone actually energized
folks can bring in money that obviously
would never have come into that race to
begin with so I think like you know if
when it comes to money I don't think
that's necessarily a zero-sum you know I
do think that that sometimes it's
difficult when people get sort of
electrified but some of these statewide
races that it's definitely I'm gonna
bail on that just because it's like how
we can't really do anything else
I can't monitor it while we're doing
stuff so I'm gonna bail on that I didn't
I forgot he has the same phone system I
have and we were we were gonna sit on
hold and listen to that okay so maybe
we'll try a different one if we get
other ones the Badger a-- says for
independent media and Phobos moon for
428 Canadian says good luck Canada good
luck
Canada thank you appreciate that very
very much let me say a few other
thank-yous to people who have been
signing up and supporting the show David
Tillery not Killary
not Hitler II David Tillery is now a
five dollar-a-month patron
thank you David I appreciate that so
very much I want to say thanks to Nina
trim Beth who has signed up at a 40%
discount using the coupon code vote soon
18 which expires tonight at midnight at
WWJ pakman.com I want to say thanks to
Michael Costello who has done the exact
same thing and is now a member and you
can do the exact
same thing and have I I will say nice
things about you these are all amazing
people these are all great I would say
Hannity's these are great Americans but
I don't know if they're Americans and
quite frankly it makes no difference to
me because everybody's welcome as David
Pakman show members
ww join pakman.com let's see if we can
get some updated numbers and then I will
go back to the phones twenty-nine thirty
five Democrats twenty-nine Republicans
thirty five and as you can see the map
starts to fill in east to west as polls
close in later and later time zones or I
guess earlier time zones time zones
where it is earlier so far
Democrats have gained two seats and
Republicans have lost two seats based on
the results so far very important bit of
information in the Senate we are still
at 31 to 40 to 31 to 42 over in the
Senate Florida numbers let's get an
update there now with 79% reporting a
rick Scott has a 64,000 vote lead still
very much within reach but the more that
number goes up the worse it is for
Democrats and it's starting to look
worse and worse and for governors it is
8 to 10 we had seven eight for a while
it is now 8 to 10 we are filling in the
map in Rhode Island we do have Gina
Raimondo the incumbent who has a secured
reelection in Massachusetts as I
mentioned Charlie Baker has secured
re-election in Tennessee Bill Lee is
despite only three percent reporting
ahead by so much that it has been called
in his favor the Republican and an
Arkansas incumbent Republican governor
ASA Hutchinson even with under one
percent reporting has has has had that
called for him Sam set the call back in
so I'm actually going to try that let's
see if we can call back in
thank you for calling into the majority
report Sam will be with you shortly
calling that is also problematic in
terms of their as far as I know there is
no congressional races in Transylvania
not of interest of us tonight calling
from a t17 area cutting my week well
that wasn't that was no hanging fruit
that was a little hanging fruit call
from the 207 area code hey Cole so
Pritzker is now your governor Congrats
so for people who don't know what's
going on we're listening to sam cedars
live stream he texted me and said to
call in and he's going to put me on and
we're going to be able to see what's
what's going on over there
yes the well I mean I feel like that
theory has gotten pretty threadbare I
think what the caller is referring to is
that the the idea was that if that
Donald Trump would destroy the
Republican Party and by 2020 by 2018 I
think he said that the Democrats would
take the Senate and the house and other
believe Linda can I present Jimmy doors
idea what's going on over there I don't
I mean I think then there would be a
mass outpouring in streets I think it'd
be like the president in 2019 because
they amend the Constitution so just let
Trump win and then there'll be a [ __ ]
revolution but you motivated
this is weird
now we can't hear anything it's very
strange still on them how weird is this
what we're still on hold with Sam but
all of a sudden we lost the show let's
try it once more
thank you for calling into the majority
report Sam we'll be with you shortly
or motivated by that change come from a
307 area code who's this where you come
from
hey this is Josh I'm so dumb
I told Sam to look for my cell phone
number I'm not calling from my cell
phone I'm calling from Skype let's see
if now we can get on yeah and then
watching the results with with great
stress yeah
the stress is warranted I think and you
know but with that said if your stress
my stress will not do anything wild
number nineteen ninety five percent am
you there Gilliam is down by one point
two percent of 95 percent in oh [ __ ] you
you racist Garf I'm didn't look good
look at those two people on stage and
say I'm gonna pick the small defensive
oily guy with connections to every type
of opponent individual imaginable who
looks like a pedophilia poster over the
nice mayor from telasi like that is that
this is this is how deep the races you
know to be huh now that is a pure race
39% in the battle is up by 52% to 48% I
mean you know that's a perfectly nice I
think this is another one if you
we'll go in a room and say I would spend
12 years with Ted Cruz over better or
work then you should be
institutionalized I mean listen we're
talking about you know Texas isn't sort
of like the pure south neither is
Florida for that matter well uh but
there is a slight difference between
federal Roark and Andrew Gilliam yes
that was kind of my point right wasn't
that sort of my point let's see if you
can yeah I mean you know one of the
things that have that mention a [ __ ]
criminal sellout last week I was on a
Hayes's program and there was this
notion of wine could be very positive
and I said you know and I said this on
this program but it's a lid on the
election will show us something very
very dark about our country I mean it's
one thing about you know like sort of
the you know I think here's the plan
all weights like one more a call and
then we'll probably have to bail you
know come--and and mistakes by the
campaign and than that but you know
we're now at like we're more or less at
you know that sort of I want to say gut
check time but I basically want to say
like things are pretty obvious now right
like there's no you know to the extent
that the American public can be anything
can be communicated to the American
public things are pretty clear but we'll
see how close race is a great example
you know Vermont is not the south right
right right right right right I mean
that's not I mean that's we have a long
way to go Josh I appreciate the call
hang in there we'll all come skiing it's
your best friend Chris [ __ ] cell up
Hayes hold on for one second I was doing
this impression rest of nice I don't
want to get through that yeah absolutely
I don't I got you she believed David
Pakman is telling me the wrong number
that he's calling from an alibi
Noemie she has a future-oriented vision
for New York City and the Democratic
Party wants to work across this it is
represent the Bronx I'm trying to find
it now let's see if tell me it's a
weird-looking number from Skype
I literally the Transylvania that was
what I need you to do tell me what the
idea is all right very per second I'm
gonna get a pizza and a let's listen to
hate oh man oh [ __ ] Hayes all right so I
guess I got a call myself man this is
just a mess let me do it real quick and
then we can just move on and then we'll
know exactly what what the what the
number is and then we're gonna move on
to other stuff it could be funny to get
on Sam's on Sam's show and see what
they're doing but it's like how long can
we deal with you deal with that you know
okay plus one let me see exactly what
number it comes through as restricted
great all right we'll try to get back on
after with with Sam but that is that is
a real disappointment restricted is not
going to be too useful okay
let's get some updated results here
because there is a lot going on we are
seeing very different numbers in Texas
than what Sam just mentioned let's start
over with the house 35 to 40 but the
important number is actually how many
seats Democrats have gained because even
though it's it's 36 to 40 now what
really matters is the net change and
right now Democrats are plus two based
on what what what the previous situation
was in the Senate 31 to 42 still and it
is looking increasingly not good in
Florida unfortunately we now have a
florida situation where rick scott has
taken a lead of 70,000 votes
it's persisting at 70,000 despite 83%
reporting and then over in Governors
Ville eight to ten and the numbers are
looking increasingly poor in Florida as
well where we had really high hopes 77%
reporting and I know people will point
out hold on David it's only eighty three
eighty nine thousand votes but with 77
percent reporting what that means is
that the votes that are left have to go
in favor of Gilliam by a bigger and
bigger majority to make up the gap the
closer you get to a hundred percent so
it's it's truly not good it's it's
really not a good situation there and
ultimately what's going to matter are
going to be the the plus minuses and
again seven Democrats seven seven
Democratic governors not up for
re-election seven Republican governors
not up for re-election and that that is
that so I I am
I'm not hugely optimistic anywhere other
than the house where we do have
Democrats as plus two plus two for
Democrats in the house that's really
where I've been saying that the
Democrats have the opportunity let's see
what's going on with live coverage he's
gonna win this race tonight all right
Bill Nye got joining us from Atlanta
thank you very much bill it's good to
see you
so back with our our experts here at the
table I have two Chris Buskirk I have to
come to you on this question of whether
the south is ready to you know it was it
was a big story when the South went from
Democrat to Republican yeah decades ago
and there are people who were saying all
right and let's see what's happening
over on Chuck Todd let's see what his
analysis is of the situation
I will say this about Donald Trump and
the Republican Party they were much
better
why can I barely hear this channel the
level is just embarrassing lilo over
there I don't know what is going on with
them over there okay so if there are any
specific races that you want me to focus
in and look at on the map I am glad to
do that we are continuing to get the
house map filled in more and more 38 and
44 but still the important number is in
the upper left democrats have gained
just two seats so far and they need to
gain 25 in order to take over in order
to take over control - 18 - 18 half plus
one one more than half I guess it's an
odd number so I don't know if that's the
the right way to sort of say what the
math is but 218 is what is necessary to
take over control in the House of
Representatives and still a long long
way to go let's do a couple of Super
chats why don't we because I am missing
a lot of action that is happening here
Irving Rocha sent a dollar super chat
Thank You Davide vent Ronay sent a two
dollar and fifty cent Canadian super
chat saying the children of the left
will rise yeah Jesse Lee Peterson talks
about the children of the lie and I
guess we are the children of the left I
don't know Joey tech talks sent a $5
super chat I'm almost homeless but I
figured I'd send you something and
support the show Joey if these are your
last five dollars I don't need them and
if there were a way to can I even refund
that I can't there's no way to refund
that I don't need people's last dollar
please I believe that supporting
independent media is extraordinarily
important but the reason I do it is not
just for the people that can pay it's so
that it's available to everybody
regardless of ability to pay which is
why when I see Andrew roan becoming a
$2.00 a month patron when I see Miguel
Martinez signing up at join pakman.com
with the coupon code vote soon 18 when I
see all of these great people saying you
know what I can afford it I can afford
$1 a month on page
I can afford three dollars a month for a
discounted membership that subsidizes
everybody getting the show without
paying anything which is the whole idea
we want to make this available to as
many people as possible so thanks to
everybody who's been contributing and
we're gonna keep thanking those folks
Ryan Couture is asking David what is the
Colin number the Colin number is in the
video description and it's six one seven
eight three zero forty seven fifty on ie
seventy seven for three dollars says do
I think Stacey Abrams should contest her
loss oh man let's look at some of that
information so we're looking at governor
and we are looking at Georgia let's see
what the numbers are right now has it
has that been called by the way sixteen
percent reporting and Brian Kemp is up
by almost a two-to-one margin you know
two to one that was not that was nowhere
close to that let's see if we can pull
up Real Clear Politics and see where the
polling was on that race election 2018
and governor polls and we are looking
for Georgia the recent poll is from
yesterday actually the the most recent
poll did have Kemp plus 12 so I don't
know I mean the the issue is right now
he's plus 26 you know if he ends up plus
26 and the polls had him plus 12 that is
very very odd but it wouldn't have
flipped the race and there has been so
much nonsense in that race that I it's
almost certain that votes were
suppressed with Democratic votes were
suppressed the question is would Stacey
Abrams have have had won without that
voter suppression and I don't know the
answer to that so I think it's to you
know it's it's 856 on election night and
it hasn't even been called by the New
York Times although it's very quickly
going in that direction I don't know if
networks have called it I don't know the
answer to whether that should be
contested yet
Brian coldy is that it is Brian coldy
it's my friend Brian called the great
show keep up the good work Dave I'm kind
of related to Brian coldy now it's a
very long story but I can assure you
that growing up if you had said to Brian
coldy and I you guys will one day be
related in some way but by marriage I
would have said you're crazy how am I
gonna end up related to Brian coldy but
somehow I kind of em I'm common law
related to Brian coldy although I don't
think we have that in Massachusetts
Cleese Oh final 22 I know Kansas is red
but district 3 is a big deal to me well
let's take a look at that let's look at
the house and let's see what's going on
in Kansas and wow I didn't realize
Kansas had so few districts district 3
is where is Kansas district 3 can't even
find it on this map one for two ah there
it is Kansas district 3 let's see what's
going on so we have oh right I forgot
that I'm timed out on these let's see if
I can just look at the data this way
kansas district 3 under 1% reporting
incumbent republican Kevin Yoder is up
basically two-to-one over a Cherise
David so it's very early we'll keep an
eye on it we'll see what ultimately
happens their costume Co with a 20
Canadian dollar super chat thank you
second biggest super chat of the evening
love the show David from Canada Thank
You Love Canada
Sam V $10 love your show raised right of
conservative home schooled realizing
throughout my 20s how much propaganda we
believed hoping Christians wake up let
his truth shine in God commands us to
love I'm not religious but if I imagine
what would God's approach be wouldn't it
be that we should love and that truth
matters and some of this other stuff
that Sam V says I think the answer is
yes for sure okay let's
go back to so I don't think we
necessarily need to go back to
RealClearPolitics although we can 39:49
but most importantly just plus two for
Democrats so far need to gain more than
that to take over control in the Senate
32 to 42 32 to 42 and still waiting for
results in a number of key places you
know on when we were just listening in
to sam cedars show he was talking about
50% reporting in texas we're seeing 2
percent and bado
up I think he said roughly 50% and bado
down maybe the New York Times is just a
little slow on the uptake in terms of
updating here we are getting data from
Tennessee and it is looking really
terribly terribly bad for Phil Bredesen
we are getting data from Michigan and 3%
reporting and debbie Stabenow is up
slightly only 3% reporting we'll see
what ultimately happens there we had a
caller from North Dakota earlier who is
interested in what was going on there
Heidi Heitkamp with only 2 percent
reporting down just obliterated
according to this 2 percent very very
early and if we look yeah I mean
Bismarck Fargo and Grand Forks we have
no data we basically have two counties
that's it so it's very very early there
don't think we can deduce too much from
it and Claire McCaskill with under 1%
reporting has taken a lead in Missouri
sheep she needs to hold that I me to
listen if Democrats want any chance of
taking over the Senate she needs to hold
that seat for sure and then over on the
gubernatorial side I'm almost scared to
look at how much worse it's getting in
Florida for Andrew Gilliam but it is
where are we right now Ron de santis is
up by still just an 80,000 vote lead but
with 80 percent reporting 79 percent
reporting and with every percentage
point additional that reports that makes
the necessary margin to take it back
even even
bigger so that could be extraordinarily
problematic if that doesn't go for
Democrats and how is the Senate going by
the way in Florida also not very good
bill Nelson is now down by not that much
51 and 758 thousand votes with 85% it's
starting to get so you I don't know what
the math is offhand but if you're down
by 0.8% with 85% reporting that means
you need to win what's left by say you
know two and a half percent
if you remain down equally with 90
percent reporting now you need to get a
five-point advantage in what so you can
see how the gap you need to make up
grows every time you get more and more
more and more reports let's see what
other troops Super chats we've got going
on here
Vince for five bucks keep up the good
work man the world needs you thank you
Stephen green bank5 Canadian dollars
best of luck from Saskatchewan Canada
Chelsea Fagin tying the second place a
high-water mark we have a $200 super
chat so far during this live stream
that's the high-water mark and we've got
220 so far actually three 20s now
Chelsea says keep up the wonderful work
David you should show Ben Jealous in
Maryland some love he's up right now
early going but still yeah we'll look at
that shortly Paul Knopf says I respect
you the most also get on the Joe Rogan
experience I'm ready to go on the Joe
Rogan experience any time any time I'm
ready to go
Nikki ray who was also a member 20 bucks
hey David voted to keep my part of
Pennsylvania blue today originally from
Alaska though and there's a chance they
gained a Democrat for governor there
this time around he was in the Senate
for a while anyway thanks for an awesome
show thank you
really really appreciate that very very
much appreciate that and a few other
thank-yous I want to do Daniel Bodine or
Bodine is a new patron for a dollar a
month thank you I really appreciate that
Paula bragg is a new member at w
eww join pakman.com thank you every
single new member and dollar a month
that we raise at patreon.com slash david
pakman show allows us to do more of the
stuff that we do that includes the
long-form pieces that includes The Daily
Show that includes improving the
production value of the show which by
the way I must say I think the show is
very very close to sounding better than
ever and this is over the last five
years we've made so many improvements to
the visuals of the show which only
benefits people who watch if you listen
to the podcast or listen to the radio
show you don't really care what the show
looks like you don't care if I've
completely plagiarized sam cedars set
because you're just listening and this
time one of the main priorities was we
want to improve the sound drastically
and we've had some issues but we've
we've made a major effort in that
direction and it's all because of the
support we get from people so the 40%
off coupon code for membership expires
at midnight tonight that coupon code is
vote soon 18 up until midnight tonight
Eastern you can get or is it because I
never remember do they expire at
midnight Eastern or midnight Pacific in
any case you've got a few hours you can
get a membership for 40% off you get all
the bonus content all the commercial
free content all that stuff and you can
keep that discounted rate as long as you
want you want to keep it for 5 years
absolutely fantastic but you've got to
use that code by midnight Eastern or
Pacific vote soon 18 at WWJ uncom and I
will thank every single one of you that
signs up including Leland Michaels who
has just signed up at WWN pakman.com
really really appreciate it thank you so
very much okay I had a couple of other
why don't we go back to the phones
briefly and I'm gonna try to get
reconnected to my own phone system here
let's see here we go thank you for
calling in to the David Pakman show
please do not use speakerphone have your
question ready
and listen for David to call out your
area code 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 I'm just
gonna put myself on the line and then we
can go to uh let's start with Sean from
Denver Sean from Denver go ahead hi
how's it going good Sean what's going on
I honestly Wow thanks right uh I
honestly just gotta say man this has
been crazy this this election cycle I
just got to think like the Democrats
have been failing so hard and it's been
crazy me nuts like watching these votes
I was calling it this is why I was
predicting because at the end of the day
they don't stand for anything and they
don't fight for anything the only thing
they do is they get the crap kicked out
of them by Republicans and cry to the
voters like who put us in power and it
does nothing like kiss with a Claire
McCaskill put an age at pie it into um
it says FCC who repeal men neutrality
that's Claire McCaskill she's about to
lose her ascendancy and what we have is
a democratic party who doesn't stand for
anything doesn't fight for anything and
was really happening is they're
destroying an entire base because
they're no one's willing to back them
because all people think and when were
late to when we talk about Democrats is
this weak minded this week politic
bullcrap where they're not willing to
stand up and fight like Kavanagh like
I'll just say one thing and go back to
you but like Kavanagh Chuck Grassley was
willing to put a potential attempted
rapist on the Supreme Court without a
thorough investigation if you had
Democratic senators one after the other
coming out on CNN and MSNBC saying at
the end of the day that Chuck Grassley
say his name Chuck Grassley doesn't care
about putting a potential attempted
rapist on the Supreme Court if they did
that day after day do you think Chuck
Grassley what did King change maybe had
an investigation may be allowed the FBI
to look at this stuff
want to talk about the Family Values
party you were talking about a person
who maybe you potentially try to race
somebody think it was Mitch McConnell
they didn't fight on any of that they
just came out and said well I disagree I
think
FBI investigation was substantial a one
[ __ ] because it was a facade and we
don't have people willing to fight for
this and and he's just and it's just
like me as a person who thinks that the
left means to have a backbone to fight
Republicans and by evil it's just been
in the same nightmare you are shot out
of a cannon and I can't disagree with
basically anything you said and I am
ready to announce that I am abandoning
the Democratic Party right now oh wait a
second I've never been a Democrat so I'm
not I'm not I guess I'm not really doing
that Sean you're so shot out of a cannon
stay on with me let's take the next call
together okay I'm gonna let you feel
this next call let's take a listen we're
gonna add to the conversation our caller
from the 774 area code you're on with
Sean who I warned you is shot out of a
cannon tonight who's this from 774
that's you yeah what's going on this is
a Massachusetts specific question okay
do you think that I obviously
strategically having mass as like a safe
state for Democrats is generally a good
thing but do you find it personally
frustrating that the race like really
your vote doesn't count like it doesn't
seem like it counts as much like it
seems like if you were in Texas voting
for bado
you know there's more that you're you're
like sort of doing their same thing was
floored I was Gilliam do you ever feel
that yeah this is the case and Sean I
want to get you in on this because I
know that you're gonna be
extraordinarily fired up by this
question yeah obviously we would all
like to be in a state in an election
where we feel like our vote will have
the most impact and that's just not the
case in Massachusetts there's a lot of
internal stuff that our votes do make a
difference on in some places it's just
not close and it doesn't Sean what do
you think of this question okay thanks
man it's education and this is what I
was saying when 2016 happened I was on
Jimmy Doris ICA's what I thought and I
mistakenly thought was when Trump gets
elected the corporate media is going to
be like no we have to talk about
policies now like this has to be
policies we need to inform the American
public on what's going on and then it
became stormy that the Daniels for 30
minutes on the hour every hour on CNN
after day for like weeks rate I was like
this is [ __ ] because what was really
going on is that we don't actually have
a populace that's informed on issues
because of the fact we're not talking
about the issues and so what my plan was
after 2016 was you had a lot of
energized people are like what do we do
you organize around the issues what we
need to do is start educating people on
the issues the issues that are important
understand what the propaganda is
understand with the lack of reality the
lack of like truth that we have not only
from the media but from the corporate
Democrats and corporate Republicans well
and work to educate the population so
like what we need to start doing is
organizing around the issues talking to
people we got it good I think that that
gives us a sense I don't know if it
relates it all to the question but I
love it Sean take the energy and now use
it for the next two years and let's do
good things with that really appreciate
the call 774 I don't know if that really
addressed your question but it was very
very high energy I mean I can't complain
yep I agree with you all right 774 new
bedford love new bedford thanks for the
call really appreciate it
let's see man it is it people are
getting this is the time when people
start getting very very agitated let's
see what's going on 647 has been holding
47 minutes no one has ever ever held on
our phones for 47 minutes so let me go
to 6 for 7 and see what's going on yes
we you are barely audible I'm going to
crank you up as much as I can but please
do speak up ok that's ok
[Music]
yeah and the thing is I'm 19 years old
voted twice and the two times I voted in
Canada the Canadian citizen I voted on a
paper ballot so like I don't understand
why you like the logistics of using a
voting machine if it has a potential of
being glitchy you know being
why not you don't understand why anyone
would even suggest using electronic
machines rather than paper ballots
you're saying I don't know I use a paper
ballot right and the thing is given that
there are like instances of voting
machines being glitchy right well there
are some advantages to using voting
machines over paper ballots for example
if something needs to be changed on the
ballot you don't have to reprint all the
ballots for example ballots can't be
physically lost but you have a whole new
set of vulnerabilities so I think you're
apt I mean this is what the debate is
about there are people who are saying
based on the problems we have we got to
get off of the voting machines and go to
paper ballots and then there are some
others who say no the paper ballots
alone don't make sense
we need machines but let's have a paper
backup that it prints a sort of receipt
for what selections you made but this is
like one of the fundamental issues
around every single election 50 states
every single one with a different voting
system different voting machines it's a
mess yeah ok I appreciate the call and
thank you for calling we can just bit
your level so low we can barely hear you
so I'm gonna let you go but I really do
appreciate the call let's go next to our
caller from 9 to 9 who has also been
holding almost as long nine to nine Iran
oh that's me that's you all right oh hey
Pakman on this election is gonna be
crazy and honestly yes it's back and
forth
definitely I'm tonight it's gonna be
crazy
I think the Democrats definitely need to
work on them a lot of things a lot of
things we need to stop focusing on Trump
and build up our ideas and our I'll okay
that's the word our you know everything
like that our values and stuff like that
you know definitely I'm fighting Trump
is definitely important but I'm gonna
try myself but I like the thing from
both sides of the parties sure so I
think that's definitely something they
needed to do before this but um I still
think that um with all the things Trump
is doing especially with that on full
citizenship that came out they're
definitely gonna get a good amount of
votes so it's definitely going to be a
strong back and forth so they said
you're not what what are your are you
you say you're not a Democrat
but what are your politics um nerve um a
moderate a moderate I can see I can see
but good in bed and a lot of parties you
know I don't like putting a label on
them like no for other agree with some
people do you like Trump on some issues
um certain certain issues Oh might not
completely the issue itself the way he
goes about it his implementation of a
lot of things is wrong and the way he
brings forth his ideas but on certain
things though basic the basicness of
certain ideas definitely I can agree
with but Trump himself as a president
I'm not too successful so far but so
aside from the way Trump presents some
ideas are there actual things you agree
with like like for example um mom the
whole you know Mexican with the whole
illegal immigrant and all that the thing
that you know about him all the
attention from the beginning definitely
on illegal immigration is a problem but
um the way he went about that legal
immigration is a problem but I think we
should be focusing more on um reform he
didn't speak anything about reform it
was all about railing against these
people no I'm a I really want to think
this through for a second because this
is interesting so yeah I said is there
an issue you agree with Trump on and you
said well I agree with Trump that
immigration is a problem but I disagree
with him about immigration and I am NOT
immigrant undocumented immigration sorry
you Crump that undocumented immigration
is a problem but you don't agree with
his approach to it so does approach yet
definitely well hold on I'm trying to
get the think this through but you're
sort of interrupting me I want to really
focus in on the question so it's not
really an issue you agree with Trump on
then right because almost any elected
official says undocumented immigration
is a problem isn't it only their
approach to solving it that matters and
you said Trump's approach is not an
approach you agree with so let me let me
ask the question almost the same way but
slightly different is there any issue
you can identify where Donald Trump's
actual approach and position is one that
you agree with and think he's done a
good job on
I'm up you said you repeat that sorry
can you identify an issue where what
Donald Trump has actually done in other
words his position and approach not just
saying X is a problem does anybody can
say X I'm definitely on probably if I
pick one example on the tears the tears
were from nations of China so yeah
definitely not the fat the fact that
he's even indulging in something like
that I do agree with wait a sec so do
you agree with the tariffs as a policy
decision or you just like that he's
doing something he's do he's making that
a major point of contention that we have
you agree on the decision to put tariffs
on China which means yeah now put
retaliatory tariffs on US soybean
farmers are getting crushed are the
stuff we buy will cost more which will
crush the middle class like you agree
with the policy
yeah but it's not that simple Pakman
mr. pac-man it takes it's a lot more
complicated than that you can't just
break it down into the certain way tell
me if the way bean farmers are going to
be owned this morning it's a very
simplistic way of looking at it if you
were to speak the actual economists you
know tariffs are something that we've
been doing since the beginning of
America basically and so appeal to
tradition that's saying that we've been
doing something for a long time is not
an argument that it's a good idea I'm
not using medicine are now I'm saying
that on so it's not such a big way yes
people are going to be affected in both
nations okay so the end goal of it is
then goal of it is but not make sure
every American is going to have this
great um what's the word like
non-consequential on tariffs the end
goal of it is to put pressure on a
number nice in where we have the
leverage above the mastered in time yes
they're going to hit back of course okay
- but on ok let's talk through it then
so Trump puts tariffs on China China
puts tariffs on us what's the next thing
like what's the next thing that should
happen now for the tariffs to succeed
well I'm not an expert on the test I
just but what the fact that he's even
going against is what I
because you asked me to give one example
but not again another expert on the
terrace itself
I realized dog yeah okay good thank you
for the call appreciate it um I think I
hope I gave that enough time for us to
suss out exactly what what the story is
let's go to our caller from 701 caller
from 701 go ahead hello David
yes Herman we can hi David so my name is
Paul I'm from Fargo North Dakota alright
I was just curious what you think about
Heidi Heitkamp possibly losing I've got
to I've got two questions yep
do you think that she's too much of a
Dino if she loses and it won't make much
of a difference and then one of the
questions okay let me answer the first
let me answer the first one first yeah
Heidi Heitkamp is not the most
progressive senator but she certainly
took the left of so joe Manchin she
doesn't vote at the Trombly nearly as
frequently as Kevin Cramer would if he
wins and right now it's looking okay for
him with 5% reporting he's crushing her
by a two-to-one ratio but so I think
that yes she's not a progressive in in
any kind of real sense but for North
Dakota is it possible that she has left
as they would elect right now maybe and
and I think that if if Kevin Cramer
defeats her that's not good for the left
right and I had one last question sure
should we have a liberal who is
extremely tough pumps his chest was
honest real and actually gives factual
information as a president do you think
that we should shift towards tough guys
being leaders in the Democratic Party
with intellectual rigor could that be a
realistic approach for the Democratic
Party what do you think of that so
you're saying if in 2020 a tough guy
Democrat in the style of Trump but on
the left ends up winning is that a model
that the left should approach big
picture but it's actually honest and
presents real fact
is not i sell value truth I still value
truth and accuracy as a viable and
important element of political platforms
unfortunately a huge part of the country
no longer does so would I like to see
that of course is it actually what is
going to determine who wins in 2020
doesn't seem like it I mean I hate that
that's the reality but that doesn't seem
like that really matters anymore I wish
you would I know I know I appreciate the
call thank you so much let me take one
more there's one other person who's been
holding more than a half hour and then
I've got so much else to catch up on 804
area code go ahead hi hi hi
how y'all doing good thank you yeah
Virginia is mostly blue but we have some
Republicans you know infiltrating us
here and there right I'm proud to say it
has been pretty much called
contain PCC and from my district which
is district number seven everything is
looking pretty darn good she's got a
pretty good lead for our spam folder and
yeah so just for people who know just to
tell people let me just tell people
what's going on so Dave brat is the
incumbent Republican in Virginia 7th
district we've got the results up on the
screen for our audience he is down with
94% reporting by 5 I'm seeing only 500
votes which really isn't very much it's
0.2% do you have like more updated data
than that okay and to the guy who like
I'm in Independence all right my son and
I are both independent today was his
first time voting and we spent the last
three days researching people and
researching what the amendments were and
everything and last year and 2016 he was
very apathetic about you know voting he
didn't really it wasn't into it like
with the banks of Trump he I'm actually
thankful to Trump I cannot tolerate him
I kind of you know have a great disdain
for the man but he in the disease that
is going to cause the vaccine that is
the Democratic rape what I'm also
thankful of is we are seeing a whole new
breed of Democrats that are running they
are true progressive Democrats not the
corporate Democrats you know that's why
I didn't vote for Hillary because she
was more of a corporate and not really
caring for us little people so I'm
praying for Florida I'm praying for you
people but as far as he goes
Trump opens in the great orange gigantic
super uber that is sitting in White
House I don't see how anybody could
support him because he is just oh my
gosh there is not a single solitary
thing that he has done that in cowboy
okay we just lost you thank you I
appreciate the call that was a very
strange noise I think the point is she
does not like Trump and she's praying
for people in a lot of different places
and that's a very very good thing we're
getting a very strange sort of feedback
noise on the call system so let's leave
it at those calls for now I will keep
the phone lines open and then we can go
back to the phones in a bit and
hopefully that strange noise will clear
let me do a couple of Super chats
because there are a lot here that I have
fallen behind on let's see what we can
see here okay to cider tech says hey
David love your show can you check how
the race in Illinois 14 is going Trump
won by three points Illinois 14 let's
take a look at that Illinois
16 Illinois - where is 14 must be some
easier way to do this this is 1315
12 where is that 14th district I can't
find it
11 some of these are very very odd there
it is 14 okay in illinois' 14 it's so
small I can barely even find it Lauren
Underwood is up 53 to 47 over the
incumbent Republican that is interesting
if I don't know that Trump won it by
three points but if he did 34 percent
reporting it's not nothing having a
Democrat up by six points over the
incumbent is a good thing and maybe that
would help
we still have Democrats having only
gained two seats which is not not nearly
gonna cut it so let's hope that one goes
well knowledge gizmo says how can we be
sure Republican votes were not thrown
out I mean I don't know do you have
evidence that they were I don't know how
can we be sure any votes weren't thrown
out I'm not sure I understand that one
Matt Chavez 499 David is there any way
you can get access to the White House
press briefings and really challenge
Sara Huckabee Sanders I think the answer
is no I mean we don't have if I go down
to DC I miss a show and I don't think
there's a good chance of me getting in
there I can't imagine the White House
would grant me credentials but I would
love to do that that would be
interesting Jackson 10 bucks hey David
love your show would also love to see
you on Joe Rogan what are your thoughts
on a parliamentary mixed-member
proportional system like New Zealand has
I have spoken out favorably about those
proportional systems before from a leak
from up from a constitutional standpoint
is it even really worth discussing at
length for the u.s. because it would be
so difficult but I am in favor of those
systems and would be very interested in
seeing the the u.s. explore it the
downside to it can be that you can end
up with real genuine extremists who
might not win any seats in in sort of
first-past-the-post elections end up
holding some seats and that's that's not
a great thing
diamond girl diamond girl oh eight sends
a $2.00 super chap Steve B for $10 has
some good news from Florida former
felons who have paid their debt to
society have their voting rights
restored good news offshore drilling
shot down good news and Greyhound Racing
banned all
so very good news pooper scooper five
four three two one for $20 for $20
contribution then we've got one for 200
is anyone gonna do 201 and put 200 out
of the leaderboard just saying it could
be interesting pooper scooper says hey
David I don't hear you talk about
conspiracy theories much have you seen
the documentary the money masters if not
would you be willing to I have it on a
playlist on my channel the Federal
Reserve is privately owned I generally
find that most conspiracy theories
aren't even worth debunking it's better
just not to give them any oxygen I'm
open to looking at anything you want me
to look at I am curious when I see the
money masters and the Federal Reserve is
privately owned a lot of the stuff that
would have that name I'm not making this
accusation without evidence I will look
at it first
a lot of the stuff that is floating
around with that type of name is thinly
veiled anti-semitism and I'm curious to
see exactly what what that documentary
is guitar ninja 91 says do you think the
USA is an overall liberal or
conservative country it's looking scary
right now what happened to the Blue Wave
well the Blue Wave was never happening
until it actually happens in people
going out and voting enthusiasm women's
marches all of that stuff you got a vote
and we'll see where we where it shakes
out I think overall the United States
population is increasingly left and I
think that corporate interests taking
over control of the political system
over the last 40 to 50 years have
maintained a very right-wing set of
elected officials and overarching
infrastructure unfortunately and
increasingly we see a divergence between
the political views of the people and
the way that they are represented and
that's a really really bad thing it's
actually an absolutely horrible thing
let's take a look at what's happening
over on PB let's listen in and see
what's going on just a few minutes ago
the vote that's been counted so far in
Texas Oh doughnuts so what's come in so
far and it's been counted it's the areas
that you would expect to be blue it's
entirely possible we'll see when it's
all counted that we'll see crews
actually draw even before they start on
the Election Day vote what's really
interesting to me is the regional aspect
of this in some ways even more than the
urban-rural divide so you see all right
talking about Texas there let's see
what's happening on NBC why did we lose
audio on this one now it's very strange
what's going on I'm not sure I don't
have the tab muted I really don't get
why we are seeing the audio go up and
down on some of these it's it's bizarre
quite frankly not sure I understand that
okay let's take a look at what we have
going on starting with the house we now
have a hundred and thirty-eight seats
where we have results Democrats
sixty-eight Republican seventy and still
Democrats have gained just two seats
Democrats need to gain 25 seats meaning
that they need to gain 23 more in order
to reach 218 and take control of the US
House of Representatives over in the
Senate we are now at 34 to 45 and so far
unfortunately although it does match my
prediction from earlier today
Republicans have gained a seat in the
Senate where is that by definition
because it's zero-sum means that
Democrats have lost the seat in the
Senate I mean this is this this was my
prediction but we still have a lot more
things to figure out and let's take a
look at a couple of key races let's look
at Florida Rick Scott now has a
twenty-two plus forty sixty two thousand
vote lead with only 7% left to go you
asked me right now I think that Rick
Scott wins in Florida and Bill Nelson
does not let's take a look at Texas in
Texas with four percent reporting beta
O'Rourke
leads Ted Cruz by a hundred and twenty
four twenty nine hundred and twenty nine
thousand votes it's still very early we
don't know much about that at all we do
see that in beta or a beta paedo o cruz
beta O'Rourke's home of el paso with
only one precinct reporting he is up
three to one which is fascinating
but very early he's from there so we've
still got a ways to go there and then
going over to the gubernatorial side we
have eleven to thirteen and democrats
have gained one seat in terms of
governors and that is Illinois where JB
Pritzker has defeated incumbent
Republican Bruce rauner we have thirty
three percent reporting and pritzker the
Democratic challenger winning by almost
a two-to-one margin which is stunning
but it likely is not going to hold it's
likely going to end up being a smaller
margin than that and unfortunately in
Florida it's not looking great for
Andrew Gilliam but he still could win
let's see so if I if I want to find good
news here I can find it and the good
news is that if you look at the entire
Panhandle which is all red it's all in
other than Holmes County and it's really
just Holmes County it's basically all in
so you're not gonna get any more votes
from that very red area if we look down
first of all at Orlando Orlando's
basically all in you're not gonna get
much more from Orlando but let's look at
the big three counties in the southeast
you've got Palm Beach County it's mostly
in as well so you're not gonna get too
much more there Broward County is mostly
in and miami-dade is also mostly and so
listen you've got about 300 precincts
across these three counties that are yet
to be counted you've got to make up what
is that 63 and 24 so it's close to a
hundred thousand you know a little under
90 thousand votes you've got to make up
and you have you know what percentage
of those liberal counties remaining it's
absolutely possible but it is not
looking particularly good it's not
looking particularly good there so we're
gonna continue following those results
let me look at a couple of other super
chats Joaquim Neilson sends a 17 Danish
kroner love Denmark was just in Denmark
over the summer 17 Danish kroner which I
think you have to divide you divide by
10 or divided by 20 to get dollars
anyway hey Pakman do you like Sansa
Stark from Game of Thrones I've seen 15
minutes of one episode of Game of
Thrones on a plane it was like the third
episode of the second season I have no
clue what you're talking about I just
don't know
Caesar Pacheco two dollars what is up
with proposition 10 in California not
sure how to vote let's take a look at it
why don't we let's take a look at Calif
I don't even know what that is
Proposition 10 let's take a look at what
is uh-oh not this problem again I don't
know what that let me alright let me see
if I can figure out another way to get
that going
mmm what is Proposition 10 let me see if
I can find it in another way
propositions and House districts and
I've got governor lieutenant governor
Attorney General State stuff ballot
measures okay proposition ten is I've
almost got it
remove rent control limits state
restraints on local rent control laws
would be loosened and the Costa Hawkins
Rental Housing Act which prevents cities
from applying rent control laws to
single-family houses and apartments
built after 1995 would be repealed so I
I tend to be in favor of making keeping
housing more affordable now I don't vote
in California I don't know the specifics
like question one here in Massachusetts
if I didn't know anything about it it
probably would be very obvious how to
vote but being in the state and really
doing a lot of research into it I ended
up leaving it blank because they didn't
feel strongly one way or the other about
what the
right thing to do was so I I tend to be
in favor of those rent controls but
particularly in high cost of living
states like California but I don't know
the specifics of that proposal uh Shiv
Saxena Saxena Shiv Shiv Shiv $2 what did
you vote on on one in Boston I was asked
that earlier actually and I just
mentioned it as well I I left a blank I
left it blank and I just did not I
really if I'm not sure I don't vote on
particular things and I filled
everything else out other than some
hyperlocal or not hyperlocal actually no
did I leave anything I don't think I
left anything else blank no I was gonna
leave galvan blank
he's been the Democrat in for so long
and then I said no I actually do like
the guy and I'm gonna vote for him so I
just left question one blank because I
didn't feel that I had a good a strong
feeling one one way or the other
let's what did I want to do oh I got a
catch up on thank yous we are doing 40%
off memberships for the rest of the
night the coupon code is I voted 17 and
I'm sorry it's not I voted 17 its vote
soon 18 I voted 17 was last year you
save 40% if you sign up by midnight and
you can keep that price for as long as
you want best way to support independent
media if you like what we do if if just
like three percent of our YouTube
subscribers all signed up we would be
laughing about things like YouTube D
monetization and all of that other stuff
so you can use that coupon code on our
website wwlp.com vote soon 18 save 40%
Nicole rig lot is that reg lotto has
used the code and I really appreciate
that
Jennifer Newell has used the code and I
really appreciate that and I don't know
if I already thanked Leland Michaels if
I think I did if I didn't Leland thank
you and also want to say thanks to
nikolaos why who is a $5 a month new
patron today any other new patrons that
I missed here I don't think so I think
we are basically a basically caught
as far as that as far as that goes
one other super chat actually a couple
other super chats Graham Barth pay the
damn times further website mr. Pakman I
should just get a subscription joaquim
Nielsen one dollar is 6.8 Danish kroner
do you watch house of cards thank you I
have watched every season of house of
cards other than the one that was just
released on Netflix I plan to watch it
although with the disappearance of Kevin
Spacey who I assume that they kill off
and just kind of like I assume it the
first episode will start with a funeral
scene or something like that I don't
know but I don't know that it'll be as
good and I get why Kevin Spacey is gone
but I haven't I have not I have not seen
that I have not seen that latest season
yet let's take a look at what we have
going on over here in the house anything
new nothing new at all in the House
Democrats still just up to any big
reporting going on let's see no big
breaking news on PBS a lot of too early
to calls Rick Scott Bill Nelson we've
been covering that one that one's
certainly too too early to call Claire
McCaskill could be done really tough
fight right now Josh Holley I had bit
too close to call wow this is a big
lunch to call Kyrsten Sinema martha
mcsalley this is the you Jeff Flake seat
that's open North Dakota Senate early
early but not looking good either a
really tough fight - hang on - really -
call in North Dakota
I'm watching the house number so closely
as we know 23 with enough so nBC has
Democrats at +5 right now let's see
what's going on on PBS of a state so
there's a bit of history that's been
made with this it is it's a relief for
Democrats I think Democrats expected
mark shields to hold on to the
governor's seat in in Colorado but
always a relief to see the check mark
absolutely and Jerry Paulus is as you
said the first openly gay governor to
seek the office as a male and a father
and a husband and an enormously
successful businessman member of
Congress interesting that is an
interesting race
let's see optimist 1 3 3 7 says experts
say Trump is already causing the next
economic disaster do you think
Republicans will blame Democrats when
this happens especially if they win the
house absolutely they don't even need to
win the house actually because the
Republicans if we are at the beginning
of an economic crash Democrats will be
blamed for obstructing Republicans from
preventing the crash so it's like forget
about there they're gonna blame
Democrats no matter what
no question about it Joe Rader asks how
about Minnesota let's see what we have
going on in Minnesota in Minnesota we
have a bunch of different congressional
races all but a couple right now around
the Minneapolis area I assume that that
is many the Minneapolis st. Paul area
are we have Republicans ahead we're
gonna dig into more detail on those as
we have more data over in the Senate in
Minneapolis I'm sorry in Minnesota we
have Amy Klobuchar who has already
easily defeated Republican challenger
Jim Neuberger absolutely no sweat there
and is there a gubernatorial race in
Minnesota there is and Tim Wise is is
that wiser waltz I can't actually I
think it's wise waltz okay the screen is
quite far from me as you might notice up
right now with 12% reporting over Jeff
Johnson but still
a long way to go there so Minnesota we
will keep an eye on some interesting
races there for sure
ready aim fire I get it says hey David
what are your thoughts on Governor Scott
Walker if you have anything store your
input I think he's disgusting and I
actually let's take a look at that
what's going on in Wisconsin who he
could go down this is an interesting one
Oh Scott Walker right now the incumbent
Republican disgusting guy just very very
nasty Donald Trump 25% reporting he's
down by just a little bit it would be a
massive accomplishment to be able to
take down Scott Walker it really would
and that is one we are going to keep an
eye on but no Scott Walker particularly
on his Labor Relations policy and just
being a horrible Republican someone I
want to see gone as soon as possible
Reid McMaster how about Florida House
seats like the 26th let's take a look at
that if we can Florida and they're 26
let's see if I can like zoom in maybe on
Florida in a particular way so that we
can see a little more um where is the
26th the second is way up there so I'm
guessing the numbers goes up and go up
as we go down 26 there it is okay 26 90%
whoo this is an interesting one Carlos
corbello the incumbent Republican is
very close to losing to Debbie
Makar so pal currently she leads by
about 3400 votes with 90 percent
reporting that's great and that would be
one of the 25 that Democrats need to
gain so that's a really good thing let's
get zoomed back out here so we can get a
better perspective there we go very
interesting one that that's that's a
good one and right now still just plus
two for Democrats in the house there
Florida House the 26th yeah interesting
one thanks for calling that one to to my
attention okay I want to take more call
there's a bunch of stuff I want to do
and we have big results coming up at
10:00 p.m. so let me do this let me step
away for a moment refill my water maybe
grab a fur net if we still have that
bottle and then we will dip into the PBS
coverage and I will get back we're gonna
get back on the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 this is the time if you want a thank
you right when I get back make a patreon
pledge at patreon.com slash david pakman
show in the next couple of minutes and
when I come back I will thank you and
it's going to be fantastic and we're
gonna love it and it's going to be great
that point I do want to start off by
saying like a year ago talking about a
competitive Senate competitive seats for
for Democrats what it was unheard of
because the terrain the political
terrain for Democrats in this Senate in
the Senate election is one of the worst
terrains and in decades like it was
really difficult for Democrats to do
well in Senate seats and in the house I
think I think Democrats will will indeed
take back the house and they think also
something that I had brought up earlier
is the governorships I think the
governorships are going to be some
historical wins for Democrats which will
be important in 2020 wit redistricting
we saw we made history in Colorado with
the first openly gay man who has you
know talked about his children his
family the way he's gonna be a guest on
the NewsHour tomorrow that's fantastic
that's a great plug and and we'll see
and we Illinois you know we saw some
sums we're seeing some wins across the
country in those those Midwestern those
upper Midwestern states a lot of many of
them that Donald Trump wine and so I
think that's a big win for Democrats
there as well chris buzz Kirk if you're
Donald Trump and you're sitting in the
White House tonight put yourself in his
shoes and his in his mind what are you
pleased about at this point and what are
you worried about I think I I'm pleased
that I'm my party's gonna pick up seats
and in the Senate I think that's kind of
sort of baked in the cake now I've said
for a few weeks now if probably
Republicans will pick up two to four
well I'm sticking with that I think
that's probably where we wind
and Democrats pickup in the house so I'm
not I'm not too happy about that because
that's which is the chairmanships out
goes Devon Nunez in comes Adam chef you
know we wind up with Jerry Nadler
chairing the Judiciary Committee and
this this just makes life difficult for
the Trump administration because there
is an agenda there what do you think his
strategy will be with assuming the
Democrats take control of the house what
is his approach going to be is he gonna
use the president to start the
presidential campaign tomorrow yeah I
mean I think that's it he tried against
the house immediately I mean he tried to
nationalize the this election and to
some extent I think was successful this
year and that the perpetual campaign
just continues on so any hope of
cooperation between the two parties
forget it is that is that problem I
think if we agree on setting the date
for the next election we'd be doing
pretty whoa mark a Mother's Day
resolution I think we could agree on it
just not not to pick a fight with Chris
but Devin Nunez has an agenda
I mean don't suggest please that the
chip Adam Schiff has an agenda and the
demo Nunez doesn't I mean different
nuances of the first House Intelligence
Committee Chair in the history of that
organization to turn it into a partisan
it's always been a non partisan politics
as partisan that the House Intelligence
Committee has been an island of
non-partisanship until this and I just
didn't want to pick up on one thing that
Michael Beschloss said you know because
I think it's it's important they've been
only two incumbent presidents who won
seats in the House of Representatives in
the first midterm John Kennedy in 1962
and George HW Bush in George W Bush
excuse me in 2002 both of them were in
the cusp of war his commanders in chief
there's the Cuban Missile Crisis and in
2002 we have both
to go to war on Iraq after 9/11 and I
raised that because there were questions
I had and doubts I raised about Donald
Trump's strategy why he didn't run a
good economy he would Ana's
commander-in-chief that we had a threat
the threat was the the caravan that we
had elevated immigration concern about
it to an issue and you know it's going
to be tough to argue if in fact the
Republicans emerge in better shape
tonight I think they will lose the house
I think Democrats will win the house but
it will be narrow but I think that he
changed the entire agenda of this
election into a national security
election with his immigration case well
we can imagine that the folks in the
White House are working with him now to
prepare whatever remarks he may make
tonight or in the morning if as Chris
Buskirk says it's true and they start
the next campaign tomorrow morning I'm
gonna buzz Lisa Desjardins they've been
looking at some of these new races and
new numbers that we are able races were
able to call new numbers we have and
what they mean I'm not over to you
thanks Judy over here in our here's the
deal corner we're focusing in on all
those key races we've been keeping track
of over the course of the night the more
information we get the more results we
can input into our charts you get a
picture like this let's bring up our
balance of power this is looking at
House races so far at least I set the
table for us again we can't remind
people and nothing exactly what it is
we're looking at here all right the goal
line is in the middle does it in this
case the coal line is in the middle and
you see of course Republicans on the
right the red dark red are states that
have already been called these are
guaranteed or so says The Associated
Press seats for the Republicans the pink
are places where Republicans are leading
okay so there are starting to be news
outlets now that are saying Democrats
are taking the house tonight there are a
number of networks that are starting to
call that let's see what some different
websites are saying let's just pop
around and see let's see what's
happening on CNN to begin with Democrats
Senate path is closing they
say house too close to call
okay so that's that's very very
different it does appear that Alexandria
Acacio Cortez is going to be elected
Senate CNN projects Democratic Senator
Bob Menendez with Stan's ethics probe to
keep Senate seat in New Jersey okay
there's that let's see I believe that
Fox News is indeed saying that Democrats
have taken the house
Fox News is now projecting Democrats win
the House of Representatives wood Fox
News be so sly as to say this while
voting is still going on on the west
coast to try to influence the results I
don't know would they would they do that
or are they just saying what they
ultimately what ultimately every network
is going to say I don't know let's go to
NBC News calm no this is uh not the
article I was looking for NBC News cough
let's see if we can find it nbcnews.com
NBC News house estimate Democrats have a
65 percent chance of winning a majority
okay that's not super interesting to me
so maybe we'll leave that and come back
to it a little bit later what is clear
is that in just eight minutes
a number of additional seats are going
to close officially Democrats have only
gained three seats in the house as of
right now and it is getting to that
point in the night where I assume the
calls are going to get even more wacky
it's getting to the point in the night
where I have found no fur net but very
very good whiskey and I'm gonna sample
it right now who bought this
crap no I'm kidding it's very very good
and we're gonna start hoping for the
best now in the next seven minutes we
are going to have a lot of new results
so right now plus three for Democrats in
the house we have minus one for
Democrats in the Senate so far tracking
roughly my prediction from earlier and
Ted Cruz has taken a lead in Texas but
it's just it's still very early only 9%
once we get 25 30 35 percent I think the
numbers will start to become more clear
and a lot of non surprises on the
gubernatorial side but Democrats have
gained this one seat in Illinois so far
as I mentioned JB Pritzker defeating
incumbent Republican Bruce rauner rauner
Rahner
I assume it's pronounced so a lot of
stuff a lot of stuff going on there I am
gonna go back to the phones momentarily
at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 and maybe we can
get a couple of opinions in before we
get the next round of results let me
briefly just get caught up on super
chats Nick Angelou says tell me you're
not leaving to get seltzer nope I didn't
tokima Nielsen says what's your favorite
type or brand of alcohol I don't know I
mean I don't I don't really have too
many favorites but I would say like
really good vodka is good with seltzer
water and a lime pretty simple or I'm a
fan of her I mean I'm Argentinian so
obviously I like Fernet Oscar H are you
with the vote blue no matter who no I I
mean I think that in practice I would
end up voting blue in most cases but I
am not part of vote blue no matter who
I've not even actually heard of that to
be honest Dinn child asks opinion on
Dean Heller also if the right keeps
control what does that mean for our
country in the foreseeable future are we
intolerant and racist well we will leave
the judgments about intolerance and
racism for a future day but what it
means for
if they can't even take the house
tonight is bye-bye
it's just it's two more years of this
stuff and it is a much more a much
steeper uphill climb in 2020 that's
that's what it means let's quickly check
in on what's going on with Dean Heller
because there was a question about it
in Nevada Dean Heller oh we've got
nothing so far we've got no no data
whatsoever so far okay so let me try to
get dialed in again to the call system
let's see
thank you for calling in to the david
packard show please do not use
speakerphone have your question ready
and listen for David to call out your
area code some people have been holding
a long time here let's see if we can go
to the first one just takes a second to
get everything I don't even know what
the word is for our phone system to be
prepared you have to prepare the phone
system to take phone calls let's go to
our caller from the six one two area
code who has been holding for 50 minutes
I am sure that you have an extraordinary
topic or question six one two six one
two hey how are you ma'am Hey
calling from Louisiana second district
here oh cool uh state state election you
know ballot measure that might be of
interest we currently do not require
unanimous juries in the state of
Louisiana to holdover from the Jim Crow
era so hopefully we change that tonight
that is good and I did not know that
that is amazing yes yeah they wanted to
keep the keep the prisons full so they
could keep a basically free labor force
right slavery so my question for you is
um so if the Democrats managed to take
the house what's the impact on the
tariff situation because you know
obviously Congress is supposed to have
the power at
the Constitution to regulate commerce
with foreign nations do you think they
can get allies with the Republicans to
try to take that power back from the
executive it depends on whether
Republicans want to do what most of them
probably know is the right thing or
whether they need to continue currying
favor with Donald Trump it'll ultimately
depend on on that and I don't think
we're gonna know that until things shake
out and we actually get the next
Congress sworn in but I like the way
you're thinking because it would be
great to undo that the prot you know the
problem with tariffs is it's not just as
simple as the u.s. going oh you know
what we're gonna cancel that because
other countries also have put in place
retaliatory tariffs and it's probably
going to require a type and level of
diplomacy that I've not seen the Trump
administration be capable of so far yeah
do you think in this modern era I mean
obviously lots changed since the
Constitution was written you think Trump
aside future president do you think
would be good to take that power away
from the executive you know I'd have to
think about that I I know that there are
people for whom the power of the
executive be it that they think it
should have more or more often less is
like the most important issue it's not
an issue I've studied enough to really
be able to give you an informed opinion
tonight okay and I have another question
who do you want to be Speaker of the
House oh man I mean listen I want a real
progressive to be Speaker of the House
and I would be flexible on who it is I
think Roe kana is awesome
but like is anybody talking about Rokon
of being Speaker of the House no I think
it should be the because it's not
actually really in play like it's not
really open right now I actually haven't
considered if I could just pick anybody
I think that it's good for it to be
someone with with significant somewhat
significant experience in order for them
to have clout and sort of negotiating a
status but I would want it to be a true
progressive that that's where I would
fall on it I'd have to think about like
my top five choices to be Speaker of the
House if I could pick that's a good
question though yeah
what do you think about Nancy Pelosi Oh
I mean she's way to the right of me I
think that the the most likely scenario
from what I see now if Democrats take
the house as she does she agrees to not
stay too much longer in exchange for
getting the speakership back and then
it's passed to somebody else that's the
most likely scenario in my mind right
all right thank you for the call really
appreciate it let's see if we can get
one more call in before we do some more
results let's go to the four seven five
area code or it might be country code 47
I can't tell 47 for 75 who's there
hey David it's Luke from Connecticut
oh hey Luke what's going on I just
wanted to call in um so I grew up in
southwestern Connecticut
my father was a state legislator for 12
terms he was a Democrat and he passed
away a few years ago actually jancuga
with TYT did a segment on him
and I the only thing I'm happy about
that he has not seen the state of
affairs that the country is internally
the last caller touched on you know
Nancy Pelosi being Speaker the house or
whatever and you would said that if she
did take you know the agreement be that
she would set down you know not surely
thereafter but at some point but what's
the you know do you think that
realistically that would happen once she
got the Speaker of the House do you
think that she would step down if that
was in fact the agreement and she would
I would love to see roe Connor so let me
speak I just don't think it would happen
if if Nancy Pelosi made a deal that
involves her stepping down because she
says I plan to retire after some amount
of time I think she absolutely would do
it you can make a lot of criticisms of
Nancy Pelosi but if she negotiated a
deal that includes her stepping down I
think she absolutely would do it listen
I got to go results I appreciate the
call let's see what's coming in right
now
and the audio level it seems to be so
low let's see what else by the
Associated Press which for the first
time this year is partnering with Fox
News to analyze exit polls and to
project
winners so here we go with a call this
is Kansas the third congressional
district Charice David's defeating Kevin
Yoder Kevin the pickup what we by our
calculation this is the ninth pick up
tonight for Democrats of Republican
seats Cherise Davis is a lawyer she
would be will be the first lesbian
Native American in Congress so there
number of historic first tonight and
we're able to to call this one this
again in the state of Kansas in the
third District here we go to New Jersey
and to a woman we just spoke with a few
minutes ago earlier in the last hour
Mikey Sherrill defeating the Republican
this is an open seat but it was held by
a Republican Rodney Freeling housing and
I held that seat for I think decades Jay
Weber State Assemblyman lawyer was
running to hold on for Republicans with
Mikey Sherrill retired Navy pilot former
federal prosecutor as we said I think a
little bit ago some people described it
as the golden resume for Democrats
she has able to pull that out nice win
late the polls in New Jersey closed a
few hours ago
so I think some people thought that
racer Mike here we go it was a win for
the man who wanted to be elected
president in 2012 he's now been elected
to the United States Senate
Mitt Romney there you go did the winner
in the state of Utah Willard mister
Democrat Jenny Wilson but you toe of
course a very Republican state there was
never any doubt that Mitt Romney would
win less than one percent of the vote
count in fact there's no vote counted
but the experts believe it's safe to
project Mitt Romney the winner here and
here in the state of Michigan with 22%
of the vote we are able to project a
winner for the Democrats Gretchen
Whitmer defeating Bill Schuette II the
Republican very now again only 22% of
the vote in but it looks as if and I
guess the polls they're closed just
about an hour ago but Bill Schuette II
was seen as
I'm looking looking up the resume right
now he was the attorney is the Attorney
General in Michigan it was an open seat
held by Republican Rick Snyder it turned
out to be a pretty fairly unpopular
governor there for a number of reasons
Gretchen Whitmer former former county
prosecutor that is a flip for the
Democrats refused several flips
Republican to Democrat of state houses
we've seen this evening so where do we
begin
David Brooks some good news in this all
right good so let's see where we are
right now let's start with the house as
we have been doing 86 to 102 Democrats
so far have gained six seats they need
to gain 25 meaning they need to gain 19
more as I mentioned Fox News has decided
already to call the house for Democrats
we will see when it becomes actually
official let's go over to the Senate 38
to 46 so far Democrats are down a seat
Democrats down a seat in Indiana where
incumbent Joe Donnelly has lost to Mike
Braun that is the seat they have lost
and otherwise everything is staying even
and then over on the governor's side
Democrats have now gained as we just
heard there from Judy Woodruff not only
did they gain the governorship of
Illinois
JB Pritzker defeating Bruce rauner they
also now have picked up Michigan they
have flipped Michigan Gretchen Whitmer
has defeated Bill shooty you have to be
careful when you say that one Bill
Schuette shooty Schweddy that can't be
how it said I don't know how it's
pronounced but bill lost that's we can
be sure of that because we have the data
we have the numbers so let's see I this
point I believe that really things would
have to change drastically for Democrats
to get a real shot here in the Senate
and I still think that it's going to be
minus 1 or minus 2 for Democrats in the
Senate but I hope I'm wrong
the house is really where we are going
to be paying very very close attention
plus
six for Democrats right now let me pick
up on another actually you know what
I'll pick up on calls in a second I got
to get caught up I'm sorry I have so
much stuff so I promise thank yous to
every new member and patron and it's
awesome that there are so many of you to
thank a Kyle Forester new member
Thank You Noah new patron five bucks a
month Thank You Taylor Neal new patron
five bucks a month really appreciate
that Matthew beg is a new member at WWJ
in pac-man calm Mitchel Turner is a new
member and I mentioned Nicole rig lotto
already thank you thank you thank you
the 40% off coupon code is done at
midnight it is done it might be midnight
Pacific though in which case you've got
like five hours still you save 40% you
support independent media I say your
name we all understand that you're a
great person and then we go on with our
lives and we continue doing doing the
things we do what else can I say
let me get caught up now that we are
caught up there let me get caught up on
super chats and I have a very very big
announcement to make
earlier today we had set a high-water
mark for super chats of $200 that has
now been blown out of the water by a
penny by Mike Smith who has a $200 and
one cent super chat the highest of the
evening new high he says love the show
David hoping for a blue wave but have my
doubts that it will happen you and me
both Mike thank you so much really
appreciate the support two hundred
dollars and one cent can we do $200 and
two cents is that is are we gonna see
that tonight let's see a Jain woman
power sending a to Canadian dollar super
chat and I appreciate that
tailored to marken MB CHB PharmD I guess
it's a pharmacist Taylor the pharmacist
I would say $4.99 why are some of the
polls so varied for example CBS says
Texas is at 70% reporting for the Senate
race but the
New York Times has it at 12 yeah I
really don't know let's look at the
Senate right now for beta or Rorick and
see where they have it they have it now
ad they just have it at 15% I don't know
the answer to that I mean it's very
clear that they're using different
algorithms or relying on on different
data or using different data processing
firms if that's how they do it I don't
know but what I'm seeing on the New York
Times right now is 18 plus 67 is 85,000
votes by which beta O'Rourke is losing
to losing to Ted Cruz and still a lot
left to happen we have only 6 or 7% of
Dallas reporting which is going to go
overwhelmingly for beta or Roark we have
Wow only one of a hundred and fifty-nine
precincts in Travis County which
includes Austin Texas where beta or work
right now is doing very well so that's a
lot of data still left to go we have
under whoa we have under under 10% of
Harris County which includes Houston
reporting which is trending towards beta
o'rourke but not as overwhelmingly as
Austin for example and then in San
Antonio Bexar County also a big one for
beta O'Rourke only about 1/8 a little
right around 1/8 of precincts reporting
so there's still a lot of data to go
there but I don't know why we are seeing
such drastically different numbers on
different places
Jonathon Levitan with a $5 super chat
thank you appreciate that as well and on
that note let's go back to the phones
and to our caller from the 2/8 one area
code caller from 281 welcome thank you
for holding on I know you've been
holding for awhile what's going on hey
David can you hear me
hi Ken okay excellent um I just want to
preface this question by pointing out
that it seems to me in sort of the Trump
age of the Republican Party they've gone
beyond simply being neo-cons to just
this kind of hyper populist sort of
halfway
sort of made legitimizing conspiracy
theories and basically just basing their
entire political platform off of things
that just started as imaginary human etc
yeah so with that obviously comes a huge
and hugely effective propaganda
apparatus that it doesn't seem to me
that Democrats and I don't mean
progressives I specifically am referring
to Democrats establishment Democrats
have been able to fight whatsoever so
that's why the blue way that we've been
talking about but it seemed like gonna
happen so we're in the worst case
scenario how do you say how would you
say that we can push back against the
sort of you know trumpian politics that
the Republicans have been playing on
people do we have to fight back with an
equally strong propaganda campaign or
Selzer because the things that people
are impervious to facts on these issues
so I just kind of don't know you think
we should do yes so there's a couple
different issues in they're all good
ones number one you are absolutely
correct that at this point we have seen
it's not even really like it's not
concert' trumpism is not really
conservatism in any kind of sort of
standard definition of what it means to
be conservative so that that's number
one so you have a Republican party who
is now in a situation as we get too
early to call numbers still with beta or
Roark in Texas although he is now down
by three percentage points not good you
have a Republican party that is going to
have to at some point decide are they
sticking with Trump because they're
sticking with Trump even though it's not
really conservatism because they say
Democrats are worse which many of them
do or at a certain point is the
Republican Party going to try to go back
to what they see as principled
conservatism if they do that's actually
an opportunity for the left because
honestly right now especially the way
tonight is shaping up yet again and I've
been extraordinarily skeptical of the
so-called blue wave for a long time and
we we now have Ted Cruz as a projected
winner buh-bye to beta or Roark and
other possibility buried even though I
didn't account for that in my
calculation I accounted for Ted Cruz win
in my prediction by the way
so yeah I don't know how you fight it I
really don't because truth no longer
matters and it I I don't know what to do
and I don't know that we're gonna figure
it out tonight but it's not it's
definitely not compromising on values
and policy but there are maybe going to
need to be some real changes in terms of
the dynamics of politics if the left
wants to really succeed and you know
it's there will be people who say it's
if the left just disavowed identity
politics then they'd win I I just you
know toxic identity politics are a
problem it's not a huge problem and it's
not the way to start winning all over
the place it's a problem to deal with
but it's not like the problem so I think
you're gonna see a lot of people on the
Left propose solutions that aren't
really solutions and we should also be
careful about accepting those well yeah
I mean I don't want to keep too long for
other people but just since you bring it
up I just want to mention this um
identity politics so-called and then as
well as a lot of the other things that
certain good segments of the progressive
movement America want to play or issues
they try to play up that they say we
need to address I actually think it's
terrible idea to even touch those issues
right away at least because that is the
whole reason that the trumpian
Republicans have been able to attract
such a huge you know voter base is
because they're pissed off at exactly
those kinds of issues so the more we try
to draw attention to them the more
support Trump is going to be able to get
so that's why I was asking if we should
just give up on playing to facts so to
speak and just wage kind of a
ideological campaign we don't give not
that we don't put that bond we don't
give up on facts because it still
matters empirically speaking but we've
got to realize that merely showing the
right what the facts are doesn't work
that's what we've got to realize right
yeah yeah why would you think give up on
facts but I mean if we should focus more
on a broader picture or is trying to
expose why they're full of it absolutely
we have to we have to make the case big
picture without fact-checking every
story that Trump
not good for the middle class the
average worker is not going to benefit
from the trumpian politics that's a
bigger picture thing and I think you're
spot-on and I really appreciate the call
thank you so much for calling in we do
have a situation now where Republican
control has been called of the Senate by
NBC News it looks like they're talking
to Sarah Huckabee Sanders let's see
what's going on
great night particularly when it comes
to the Senate and still some solid wins
in the house with folks like Andy Barr
but look the president's gonna fight for
exactly what he's laid out regardless of
who's in control in the house the
president's gonna be able to work with
Democrats and Republicans to make sure
we're getting things done because that's
what he came to Washington to do he's
laid out a bold agenda and we'd expect
him to continue to follow through and
have another successful two years just
like he's had the previous two years the
president announced some regrets today
at an interview about the tone that he
has had as president was there are there
any regrets about going after
immigration it looked like the number
one topic for voters this time around
was health care not at all this is a
topic and a huge crisis on the border
the president is going to focus on
problems that this country has and he's
going to continue to do that he's been
talking about this for a long time and
we want to see the solutions actually
take place we have to secure maybe the
most full of it press secretary in the
history of the United States and she it
Sean Spicer wasn't that long ago and I
think it's still it's still not even
close let's see what else is going on on
the phones two to nine area code two to
nine what's going on hi David my name is
Tyler I'm calling as a progressive from
the southernmost corner of Georgia great
obviously Stacey Abrams isn't doing
great and our race for governor and I'm
sure that you've seen a lot of these
incidents involving voter suppression
there was an incident in Gwinnett County
with malfunctioning voting machines
where people had to stand in line for
over three hours stuff like that yep not
to mention this growing news from
Florida next door's got me pretty bummed
and I'm I mean I might be moving there
next
for my master's program and I really
wanted things to turn out okay and not
obviously not everything is counted but
sometimes it's really hard to remain
hopeful down here in the Bible Belt yeah
if I had a question out of any of this
it would just be do you have any advice
for progresses like me who sometimes
feel kind of helpless well you know
listen here's the thing the good thing
about Georgia is that even though it's
not looking good for Stacey Abrams 52
provide the data I have is she's down 10
with 52% reporting but that's what I'm
seeing right now in the New York Times
the good news is that in a sense if you
live in Georgia if you live in Texas if
you're in Florida these are places where
activism has much more of a chance of
actually changing the next 10 or 20
years in those places because in
Massachusetts we elect Republican
governors every once in a while but it's
a very blue state and it's gonna remain
blue and we're gonna keep moving to the
left and doing those things but it's a
very different type of activism than
being in a place that is part of the
potentially looks like someone just got
disconnected potentially to be turned
blue I think I just got disconnected I
apologize that is really weird I got
kicked off of my own phone line which is
nuts I am gonna briefly just reset the
phone system it's it's overloaded we
have like 30 people holding I'm gonna
briefly reset it just so we can take it
from the top and continue taking calls
my advice is you can have more of an
impact in places where it's not clear
that it's gonna be a blue place because
your vote in a sense kind of matters
more and so I think that that's how I
would sort of keep my head up so to
speak let me try to get back into our
phone system thank you for calling into
the day that's crazy and I'm getting
kicked off of my own please do not use
speakerphone have your question ready
and listen for David to call out your
area code
okay I'm gonna go next to eight to eight
as soon as we get reconnected here
should just be another second or two
okay let's go now to our caller from the
eight to eight area code you're on is I
mean that is indeed hi this is Leland
calling from Asheville North Carolina
how you doing I'm just great I'd like to
first say to everyone that you should
absolutely take advantage of the 40
percent off David Pakman membership what
I just did but but also my my big
question is not necessarily for this
election but maybe for the next election
like how can I convince family and loved
ones to to like just listen to facts
because I feel like in my yeah yeah it's
very funny but like oh like every time I
think that I I debate these people and
my family and my friends they they throw
at me these these facts that just aren't
true and I often have to go look them up
after the fact because I've never heard
them and it didn't sup not being true
and I'm just I'm just not sure what to
do
I also a second follow-up question to
this but let me ask you there you go
let's say when one of these people cited
something that you later find out wasn't
true
let's say you knew right when they said
it that it wasn't true and you said that
to them would it really make any
difference to them maybe not
and only I guess that's a problem that's
the me dealing with it actually
yeah yeah yeah you're right
the follow-up question is basically just
every time I I tend to to win and one of
these arguments a family my family
member will just bring up abortion as
like the alternate points just like do
you do you support killing babies and
I'm just like most
I'm just like you know screw here like
that's such a here's the thing so that's
that's called sneaking in the premises
because you they're asking you about the
killing of babies but you I'm guessing
don't actually agree that it is killing
babies to abort for abortion let me
let's just hold that thought no I I
don't agree with that and also yes I
don't think it's going NBC News is now
reporting that the Democrats have taken
control or will take control of the
House of Representatives so as I
predicted and listen what the hell do I
know I was totally wrong in 2016 the
house will go to the Democrats and the
Senate will remain in Republican hands
that's that's what it's going to be
although we will need the rest of the
night to shake out exactly how it goes
so yeah listen I mean here's the thing
when it comes to abortion you've got to
just make sure you make them explain why
it's killing a baby right so that's the
point and yeah make them defend that
some of them will be able to in some
won't but don't cede any premises when
they're assuming the premises yeah but
thank you yes all right that makes a lot
of sense also yeah I'm I also apologize
if I didn't make much sense I have had a
bit too much to drink tonight but you
know what I mean I'm drinking some good
vodka know if you were mentioning
earlier what I mean not that we I guess
maybe we shouldn't even say because it
might appear to be a sponsored content
but and you don't have a problem you
know the problem drink I mean I mean
it's stole a vodka but okay that could
be a problem actually that may be that
could be problematic what good night yep
really appreciate it
let's see who else we've got a caller
from the 95 to area code has been
holding for more than an hour if you
hold more than an hour nine five two
then I know you're bringing me something
huge
hey thanks David how are you doing
tonight good good yeah yeah so I'm
calling from Minnesota and I have two
questions for you tonight um you know we
still don't know how things are going to
quite turn out its but with this how do
i phrase immigration is a huge topic for
this election yeah
and I have a few close loved ones who
were actually dreamers I was wondering
what your thoughts are on what what the
possibilities are for you know what
might happen in the near future of that
you know I actually think that even if
Republicans I mean the house has already
been called for Democrats as many people
are pointing out but I think even if it
weren't even if Republicans retain
control of the House and Senate I think
that the political costs to kicking out
kids who came here when they weren't
when when they were kicking out people
who came here when they were kids is
just not going to be politically viable
period so I actually think the dreamers
are going to be okay although they will
be thrown around as a political football
and if you are one of them you are going
to be worried about what your future
status is going to be with the Democrats
taking over control of the house I think
dreamers are going to be okay
I got yet do you think ye you know a
ventral pathway to citizenship is
something you see here I mean I would
hope so and that seems like absolutely
the right path forward but it might that
that may not happen between 2018 and
2020 realistically we'll have to see I
got you and then my second question was
well not really question but uh for
Minnesota for their fifth district did
you see I don't know how to pronounce
your name but I think it's a Ghia Yihan
Omar looks like she won that I didn't
say thank you that justice Democrat okay
I'm an itch I'll check that out when we
when we look at the state a little more
closely I did not see that thank you for
the call really appreciate it okay I
Brody wants to get on and I'm gonna put
Brody on briefly but Brody calls in a
lot and he's all over the place so
what's going on Brody
okay I'm just gonna say I just want to
let you know there was an emergency
injunction that was filed and upheld for
nine polling places in Houston that was
keeping the polls open until 8:00 to
8:15 p.m. in Harris County which largely
leaned towards Hillary so so obviously I
can look looking so great for Aurora I
just wanted to say as little hope nugget
out there that we are obviously seeing
still lower numbers in
Texas yep all games been called for Ted
Cruz I don't know if you saw but Ted
Cruz won as far as I know I did I did
yeah yeah
also um one last thing there is a
discord you can check out on the David
Packard subreddit which Wiesn ass now
the keynotes and come visit us there we
were happy to chat and hang out and I
love you David
alright Brody always great to hear from
Brody and he's involved in all sorts of
hijinks I've noticed okay I'm gonna go
so listen Sean from Denver is back on
the on hold and he's the guy who was
completely shot out of a cannon before
he was so entertaining that I'm willing
to put him back on maybe with like a
30-second limit or something like that
but if I'm gonna monitor the regular
chat do people want do people want to
hear 30 seconds more Sean from Denver
who was completely shot out of a cannon
let's take a look at what people people
say and if they want to hear from him
we'll put them on and otherwise no one
yes a bunch of people saying yes 30
seconds more yes one no yes hell yeah
yes yes yeah okay all right Sean I can't
I'm going to you a second time because
you were so on fire the first time but
we've got to limit it to 30 seconds go
i I got you dude I didn't for t five
seconds and then we'll be good I just I
don't generally call into shows like
this but you will you yeah you want to
say already talking about the amount of
time you've been allocated look yeah
tell me over here all right so I
honestly think like there is there is
good news in this but there's always
good news and is that we can we can
always come together the problem that I
see and I think that we've seen a lot
with this situation is that we're not
really engaged with the issues and okay
Jimmy five seconds bro I didn't think
that was gonna be on here real this real
quick but okay Sean I'm braiding this
one okay I got I got I got I got it I
got I got three so I'm gonna do
okay at the end of the day we have the
capacity to change the entire narrative
this situation and we have the capacity
to actually come together I think the
major functional problem that we've been
having is that we haven't been engaged
with each other in real consistent
manners and the higher levels consistent
we use consistency we have with each
other the better able we are to sustain
an argument like Gilliam and all that
other stuff are having problems because
of the fact that we're not getting out
our message and more so than that we're
not having the capacity to engage with
Republicans in a serious capacity like
there is a caller who talked about like
do we need progresses with a backbone
strong like Donald Trump we do but we
need people who can spit the facts you
know II mean we need people who not only
have the capacity to know the facts but
who can argue like a frickin Ben Shapiro
the thing with Ben Shapiro and I've
argued with these people they don't care
about that they don't care about the
truth they don't care about the reality
what they care about is sustaining their
narrative you mean to attack them on the
narrative and like that if a person says
they're pro-life and procreation hit
them where it counts what did Jesus say
in the parable the sheep and the goats
help the poor sick and hungry
more so than even that for I was a
stranger and you welcomed me welcome to
the Kingdom of Heaven for I was a
stranger and you did not welcome me now
go to hell for literal eternity that was
Jesus's basic method but what Jesus was
talking about he was talking about
refugees people in such dire need of
help that you need to help them this is
a message of [ __ ] Christ and the end
of the day the Republican Party has
somehow conceded or has the high ground
on the morality of [ __ ] Christianity
when Jesus were the epicenter of it all
it is insane and the fact that we don't
argue against any of this
is more so insane it is mind-blowing
read what Jesus said this for the poor
the sick so hungry the needy
healthcare freakin food Stan's freaking
refugees you want to talk about the
Christian message the Christian message
is anti Donald Trump but the people who
[ __ ] are arguing this up they don't
argue sorry I'm sorry Sean you've said
it all that was a very very long four
five seconds the chat has exploded I it
is it's a phenomena it's it's incredible
what's taking place here right now and
making a lot of good points thank you
for the passion and we're gonna move on
with the evening because we must we
simply must move on let me deal with a
couple of super chats before we go back
to back to the calls let's see where did
I leave off Johnathan Leviton $5 Thank
You skull Lord to euro cheers from
Germany how is Ojeda doing Oh Jetta
Ojeda or Oh Jetta in Virginia well let's
take a look at that
no it's West Virginia and I got to go
over to the house let's take a look here
what do we have oh man oh there it is he
is getting crushed yeah
so that's not not the best let's see is
it just me Loren's 42 says is it just me
or is a blue wave not even remotely
possible right now listen I don't know
how you define that but I thought
Democrats would take the house and
Republicans the Senate and that's what's
happening waiting to fade asks or says
two House districts in Utah could turn
blue yes Utah's District two and I'm
only seeing two as the one that that
might turn blue but it might we're gonna
watch it we're gonna watch that very
very closely Oscar H the reason there is
no blue wave is because progressives
after run against both Republicans and
corporate Democrats interesting The
Epoch 20 to take the house then take the
other house in 2020 Yannick Wilson from
Canada very disappointing to see people
still vote for Republicans anyways love
your show hope you continue doing great
making great content thank you
one of the ways that we continue doing
that is when we grow our base of
financial support Paul naath just signed
up at WWJ in pakman.com which allows us
to keep doing that can we listen let's
it's time for the rubber to meet the
road at this point our people open to
the idea of doing a
patreon challenge right now we are at
1672 patrons in the interest of 2020 and
continuing to build can we get 28 more
patrons this evening and just get to
1,700 and then we can move on to 1,800
and and and bigger and beyond it's just
a dollar a month is all you need to do
to add your name every single one of you
who does it will get a shout out from me
patreon.com slash david pakman show hit
the green I'm sorry the orange become a
patron button
I'm actually not colorblind and
everybody will get a shout out and it'll
be a beautiful thing and maybe we can
get to 1,700 okay let's see who else we
have on the phones 703 area code 703
who's been holding for an hour what's
going on hello that is you oh I'm a 15
year old from Virginia okay it's turning
blue I guess my question is uh related
to gun control a lot of people I know
say we have a people problem and I don't
really get that and it's it's obvious
that the problem is with guns we have
more guns than like any other country in
all of those countries with less guns
have less homicide gun deaths and I'm
just wondering how do i how do I try to
convince them it depends on which
argument they are making because
somebody's saying more guns make people
safer is different than someone making a
constitutional argument is different
than someone making there's a lot of
different arguments there's really no
one way I mean I think that the people
who just say it's the argument you're
referring to as guns don't kill people
people kill people and the answer to
that of course is yes people kill people
with guns and the more deadly the guns
are and the more guns they have access
to the more people they can kill like
it's a pretty there's a pretty clear
response to that but really it's just
talking points you know it's not very
substantive so what would be better is
if I were you the approach I would take
is rather than researching anti
gun arguments research pro-gun arguments
and then analyze the best way to pick
those arguments apart like make the
strongest possible version of every
pro-gun argument and figure out how to
defuse it that's my advice to you all
right thank you all right thank you
debate yeah appreciate it thank you for
the call very very much uh let's go to
our next caller from the 72 for area
code caller from 7:00 to 4:00 go ahead
72 for maybe were muted because you were
on hold but we can't hear you
hmm feel bad because they waited a while
but 72 for one last shot nope
alright let's go to our caller from the
978 area code 9 7 8 is that's
massachusetts right oh it's 9 7 8 mm
juice it's area code though probably I'm
using Google Voice on Oh
all right go ahead what's going on well
first I got I got express my my sadness
my remorse for my good pal better
O'Rourke Indiana I mean yeah a little
sad but mostly I'm wondering so it's
projected that Democrats are going to
take the house right yes what you say is
if if the Democrats want to push up
aggressive agenda what you think should
be the number one cause that they start
working towards from day one you know
the answer to that depends on what is
going on with Republicans at the time
because you can make the case that the
number one priority should be health
care but at the same time if what you
want is Medicare for all and that's just
simply not going to happen with a
Republican Senate and Trump in the White
House then maybe you pick something that
you can make progress on if that makes
sense so I tend to get away from these
kind of universal here is the issue
Democrats should deal with also it
depends
what from the Republicans you need to
counter so if Republicans do try to
follow through and do another one of
these destructive tax reform plans then
Democrats need to really activate around
preventing that from happening if they
don't do that then maybe Democrats can
really make some progress on climate
change for example so I think it's very
situational I like how you take a more
strategic approach to it because some
people might just say oh well we need to
fix health care like but is if that's
not gonna be a good use of your time
then maybe want to someone else I'm
thinking about like progressive
strategies then I'm thinking back to
another call that you just had with
another gentleman who talked about
narratives and what not being it and
then she talked about the importance of
being able to use their language yes mam
so I a little while in the past I
actually I identified as all right
and I would say that I was kind of
firmly in that for a while now I would
say that I'm I'm a lot more progressive
I've kind of been disillusioned from the
whole thing but during that time I
learned all of the right narratives
right so I could I'm now at a point
where I can heart you anything on the
right and I think that it kind of
becomes a bit more like useful once
you're in conversations to be able to
use the language I'm so I guess my
follow-up question to that all would be
is there anything right now that
Democrats are really bad asked by your
estimation when it comes to speaking the
right language yeah I mean on economic
issues the the language that Democrats
use even though I think that they are
right on the policies it Democrats are
right on economic policy within certain
bounds I mean I'm to the left of most
Democrats on economic policy but to the
extent that they are to the left of
Republicans Democrats are providing
better options than Republicans on
economic policy but the average working
person is not getting that message and
it's just a massive massive failure and
George Lakoff has written a lot about
the poor messaging from from Democrats
on all issues including economic and I
just think it's a major failure they've
got to fix that ya know I like to call a
cough I read him a lot in college I
studied uh psycholinguistics so using
language to learn
exactly part of that yeah like I did a
whole project actually once I'm off
I don't do me too that gross too much
but that's finally interesting it's a
what Trump voter saw in Trump versus
what brownie voters saw in Burma and
this is before it'd be it'd be like sure
this was during the primaries when her
and still had a shot with recipes so it
was cool to be able to show my whole
liberal classmates like what the other
side sees I just have one last question
I don't want a cup yeah do you smoke
weed no I don't ah I'm sorry
mushrooms nope nope all right fair
enough
mm good night okay thanks you too okay
let me do a couple couple super chats
here let's see here but where did I
leave off I think I left off with I'm
dying inside for two dollars love your
show do you know about article 13 from
the EU I do not I have not looked at
that yet Christina and so asks thoughts
on Colorado let's see what's happening
in Colorado so nothing going on in terms
of the Senate Colorado Democrats now
plus 12 by the way in the house even
though it's already been projected that
they're gonna win there Colorado has a
bunch of Republican incumbents who are
securing being reelected and then you
have this open district where it looks
as though
Jonah goos is going to defeat Peter you
so I don't know that much about the
internal workings of Colorado politics I
know that there are a bunch of
conservative areas as the map suggests
and then you've got some urban areas
that have oh and I see here we've got
some other Oh actually so that's
actually a big deal I didn't see that
you have in the first District no there
was another one yeah it's this it's just
so small Jason crow in the 6th district
has taken out incumbent Republican Mike
Coffman which is great good news good
news from Colorado for sure ok what else
did I want to do oh okay
so we are doing we're targeting 1,700
patrons by the end of the stream if you
appreciate the live stream if you
appreciate the show consider throwing in
a dollar
we started minutes ago at 1672 we are
now up to sixteen seventy eight twenty
two more just twenty two more patrons
and we will hit seventeen hundred the
people who were responsible for this are
Alex two dollars a month Theodore
cement Iraqis that can't be how it's
pronounced but Theodore contributing $10
a month
David Corsi two dollars a month Pierson
buck five bucks a month
Cheryl Alvarez has upped her pledge to
five dollars a month
Yehia Suri Dee two dollars a month
Yannick Wilson five dollars a month
Bryce Anderson two dollars a month
that's got to be more than sixteen
seventy eight let me refresh again
nope 1678 is where we are let's hit 1700
let's do it let's do it before the
Democrats officially take control of the
house why don't we let's see what else
is happening on the phones 774
Massachusetts area code what's going on
you've been holding for awhile thank you
oh that's you yeah um yeah it's kind of
confuse about how they're determining
that Ted Cruz Reese has been called
because it just says 33% of the vote
anymore let's take a look at it so I'm
looking at the data in New York Times
New York Times has 38 percent of the
vote and they indeed have already called
it for Ted Cruz and I think basically
everybody has so I'm not defending their
calling of it what I'm gonna tell you is
sort of how they do these things what
they do is they start looking at areas
where you would expect beta or Roark to
do better than Ted Cruz like for example
Travis County and they see are we still
expecting any significant number of
votes to come in there if you look at
Travis County which has Austin all
precincts are reporting meaning that Ted
Cruz is not going to lose that lead on
the basis of more liberal Austin boats
you look at Dallas Dallas is only about
35% reporting but they can calculate by
how many votes would bado need to win
the remaining precincts in order to
catch up and they basically
make a call they look at the places that
they don't have numbers from like
Culbertson County and Hudspeth County
Lam and Armstrong and Collingsworth all
places where Ted Cruz is going to win
and they end up coming up with something
like for example in order for beta
O'Rourke to overcome the deficit he
would need to get 68% of the remaining
precincts I'm just making that up and
then of course he's not gonna get six to
eight percent of the remaining precincts
and so they say Ted Cruz won that's how
they do it oh yeah and one thing is um
like so there's been a lot of things a
little like like with social media and
like banning um what do you think about
like social media like having like the
First Amendment as like the only like
terms are used policy meaning that
emesis illegal speech and that's not my
speech that could be banned okay so are
you saying what would I think about
making that the law no I mean what I'm
saying is like you can obviously ban
someone from like a social media
platform sure like if it's regulated
like the public utility but I mean it's
not the like if they just violate the
Terms of Use but just make it so that
it's it's if it's it only would been
kind of a like illegal speech no I get
it but so I just want to make sure I
you're saying what would I think about
social networks choosing to make that
the policy or am I in favor of mandating
that they do that um I guess anyone that
would be a public utility like I guess
you would have a choice I guess like so
if they want to have like a public
funding or something looking to get
public funding right so here's the here
let me just answer the different
versions of the question as I understand
them would I be open yeah what I think
it would be great if a social network
said our policy is if it's not illegal
we allow it sure they can do that and
that's going to impact the amount of ad
revenue they're able to get and they can
kind of make that call if that's what
they want to do it's up to them that's
lovely
would I be okay with the government
mandating that social networks allow all
speech other than illegal speech no
because quite frankly I don't think that
there's a legal foundation on which to
do that right now if you want to
the law and say that social networks
must be considered Town Square under the
purview of the First Amendment where you
can lobby to have that law change but no
I don't think that as the law currently
stands the government should say that
social networks need to do that yeah
okay and that one final question I don't
know like you mentioned like like
meditation on your one of your videos
sure um have you heard of actualized
Olivera no can you say it once more I
didn't understand that actualized org
will you girl she just has a lot of
interesting videos and use that coming
up but he talks about like things like
that
no I don't know who that is or what that
is but I'll check it out if I if I make
a note of it thank you for the call
really appreciate it we do have another
let me see another eight new patrons Wow
Kyle Hubner two bucks a month Lauren's
Schnitzer two bucks a month Marco Perez
two dollars a month Jason and reeks and
Rica's I always am unsure with the
Portuguese spellings of some of those
last names two bucks a month call kai
dish arts one dollar a month
thank you and we are targeting 1,700
patrons tonight let's just do it let's
just get to 1,700 patrons and we can be
done with it and I won't mention it
again it'll be it'll be a beautiful
thing
Democrats taking the house if you're
just joining us
Republicans maintaining control of the
Senate six one seven big Massachusetts
evening caller from the six one seven
area code go ahead hello
that's you hi I'm it's Oscar from the
sandwich shop again I remember oh hey
yeah I'm just gonna go in there today
have a sandwich and I ended up not
having time to tell you you broke up a
little bit I almost ended up in there
today getting a tuna sandwich and then I
didn't Oh Danny I'm back in Philly
anyway so also one more thing about my
question I also wanted to last time I
called you kind of implied that I was a
vegan because I worked there I'm I know
what do you - I implied you were vegan
because you worked at a
my job well not know they're in the
na'kal before you said I got it
I don't know you feel like I got a tuna
sandwich I tried to turn this out and
which knee was fine with the regarding
me so I don't know yeah I mean I'm
offended by it which is great no it's
all right but uh yeah I mean it it's
it's kind of depress Reese I mean when I
turned on your stream always kind of
hopeful about everything but then you
know the debate off a mule II took it
saw me and then the jealous and girls
men associated jetta but my question is
like even though even like I'm glad we
have a house but like to what extent do
you think a majority blue house will
realistically impact regressive progress
because to me I feel like it's it's one
of three things either their works and
then but uh a blue majority house would
you know a lot for progressive progress
or the Democrats can be too moderate and
not be able to band together to promote
progressive policies no so here's the
thing here here's where I'm kind of at
on this I think that having the house so
my prediction earlier today was
Democrats take the house they don't take
the Senate and I outlined why that's
useful number one it's useful because if
you control the house you control
investigations and now you can actually
investigate not just Trump Russia and
that far stuff but you can investigate
other stuff you can investigate fraud
and corruption in Trump's cabinet you
can investigate all sorts of potential
violations of the emoluments clause so I
think that controlling those
investigations is important not
necessarily because of where the
investigations will go but to show that
the corruption is far deeper in this
administration than just what you're
hearing about on corporate media number
two controlling the house is important
because you are in a stronger position
for 2020 I mean you just are and the
ways in which that will manifest aren't
totally clear yet but it's better to run
it's better to try to unseat an
incumbent president if you have control
of at least something than if you don't
and the ways in which that will happen
but that will be visible are many and
we're going to see them and if
Republicans are planning
on trying to do another one of these
horrible tax plans if you're in the
house if you control the house you've
got a really good shot at being able to
stop it so I think there's real value in
controlling the house yeah I do you mean
um yes you're bringing up so you bring
up a little throughout there so I
couldn't catch everything you said but
no I think the the monuments cause is in
the supposing corruption I guess that
would be good I mean I just hope that
somehow down the road I mean down the
word that progressive ideas can be
promoted in a way that allowed this to
change because after tonight I feel like
I'm questioning the effectiveness of
running on progressive ideals and when
it comes to when it comes to going
against Trump like candidates know know
you've got it what's the alternative
run is Trump light I mean you got to run
you that's where I know yeah yeah I have
you got to run out of ideas it's just
you got to run on the I agree yeah yeah
right I really have to do them I know
y'all absolutely agree with that I just
feel like you know in terms of OJ this
case say like I feel like he'd really
did that in the right way and yet he's
getting crushed right now you look at
where he's running though you can only
do so much to overcome overturn the
predominant the baseline political
demographics of the district you know
Oscar thank you for the call great to
hear from you let's we got a bunch of
new patrons I think we're gonna hit 1700
we went from 16 86 during that call to
1691 we're only nine away let's do it
folks
Eddie chavista has made a $2 pledge
Caitie nickles has made a $5 pledge
Thomas James has made a $5 pledge
Stephen coin has made a $2 pledge Erica
shard has made a $5 play we're almost
there it's 9 more dollar contributions
and we make it let's make it happen
let's make it happen by the end of this
next phone call which is with the 2 8 9
area code caller from 2 8 9 welcome
what's on your mind today
hey I originally had something else to
talk about but I have to address
something a previous caller said ok very
misinformed mm-hmm so first of all if he
wants to talk about what Jesus said
jesus said in luke 9:62 for farmers to
sell their plows and to follow him in an
itinerant lifestyle which means anyone
living in a fixed address cannot be a
follower of Jesus as this was his
explicit strategy in peacefully eroding
the tax base of Judea to non-violently
persuade the Romans to leave the
province
well secondly in Matthew 5:17 Jesus
explicitly says he has not come to
abolish four biblical laws and anyone
calling themselves Christian must still
observe certain feasts such as the
feasts of weeks they must not eat pork
or shellfish and several other things
that almost no American Christians
calling themselves Christian actually do
so anyone attempting to inject Jesus
into American politics on either side of
the political spectrum has no [ __ ]
clue what they're talking about okay
that's all I have to say at this point
because I waited long enough and was
distracted so much by that by someone
who's clearly not a biblical scholar
attempting Wow use the Bible for
political purposes well yeah I actually
have that education so yeah shots have
been fired across the bow at Sean who
was shot out of a cannon and appreciate
the call can't tell you about whether
any of that stuff was even remotely true
because I just don't care about the
Bible but it is it is interesting that
that that took place let's go to our
next caller from the 6-5 zero area code
caller from six five zero go ahead six
five zero are you there you waited a
long time I want to give you your
opportunity oh yeah that's you oh boy
are we on speaker or Bluetooth I hate to
have to ask but are we on speaker or
blues all right yeah I was on speaker oh
sorry gotcha so um so Dianne Feinstein's
beating Kevin de Leon California he's
just a Democrat and I think that there's
a lot of trouble reaching like this new
audience where there's not enough like
there's not enough people watching TV
and they're not seeing these commercials
and not understanding the issues I don't
think there
are enough people that have like really
been exposed to different people's
policies and I'm wondering at how you
think that and like this new age of you
know Generation Z and Millennials where
we're not using TV as much how we're
gonna probably like target them well
you're saying like what how to target
them technologically or how to target
them ideologically like just like
majorly how that forms do we use or
what's the messaging that we should use
yeah what like sort of both like what
kind of platforms like could we be able
to use okay well I mean listen you've
got to understand the power of
incumbency is extraordinary so the
platform's I think we know we use social
networks we use online media YouTube is
such a place now for political
advertising our shows in every state are
riddled with political ads for people
that's how that's how that's the
technological means in terms of the
ideology you've got to espouse actual
progressive values it can't be Democrat
light Democrats can't be Republicans
like it's got to be actual just
progressive values if that's what if
you--if you want to be a progressive
alternative to someone like dianne
feinstein then it's got to be full-on
progressive and by the way what's all
that noise in the background what's
going on um I'm not sure about that
sorry um no I'm just curious like are
you watching TV here no I'm just so I'm
just I don't know what that's about
probably my phone's messing up yeah but
are you sitting a stylet room right now
ya know weird because when I mentioned
it it ended but I really appreciate the
call I appreciate you waiting on hold
and I think you're bringing up
extraordinary points that Democrats are
going to need to figure out if they want
to win we have a bunch of new patrons
and we are now up to 1698
we are two patrons away from our goal of
1,700 Danni Rahman up this pledge from
$1 a month to $2 a month
thank you Mike Smith has pledged five
bucks a month
Aaron Larian has pledged I didn't see it
it was either two or five dollars a
month Nathaniel Tidwell has pledged 10
bucks a month
Jake Foglia is a $2.00 page
the Britannic is a $2.00 patron Salvador
Castaneda has made a pledge Miguel
Martinez has pledged $1 Ali Kurtz or
curtsey has Oh Ali not Ali has pledged
$2 and Amanda has pledged $2 and we are
getting extraordinarily close to hitting
1,700 patrons and we are getting
extraordinarily close to Democrats
officially taking over control of the
house although it's been called
basically everywhere as I predicted
earlier today Democrats taking control
of the House Republicans taking control
of the Senate it seems that this is
satisfying a lot of people because the
number of people on the stream are
starting to sort of drop off and before
people who have sent super chats leave I
want to get through super chats revit
Key says Republican Party hasn't done
enough damage it's a cycle Republicans
ruin things Americans then vote
Democrats Bush ruined the economy Obama
won what are your thoughts well American
America is cyclical in more ways than
just that but I agree with you yeah
Jackson says David what are your
thoughts on a direct constitutional
democracy I don't buy the tyranny of the
majority argument because otherwise its
tyranny of the minority what we have now
with Republicans yeah that's a bad
argument against the direct
constitutional democracy I think that
there are pros and cons and we're gonna
do it we're actually we're gonna work on
a video we're doing a video I want to do
a video and I've started thinking about
it where we're actually going to go
through some of those systems one by one
Oscar H says it's frustrating to see how
people give corporate democrats 40 years
of nothing but give progressives just a
few tries and then give up absolutely
fair point and well made on ie 77 for
anyone who does care about the Bible
please check out Bryon's and
great books for politically progressive
Christians very very interesting not
familiar with him art Flores has become
a $2.00 a month patron which now puts us
at OU and somebody else must have signed
up because we are now at 1700
well I think that the emails I get and
those numbers are on a delay thank you
our patreon has been dying for the last
six months because we've been so busy
with the studio move and with so many
other things that I've barely mentioned
it and 1,700 is awesome and we want to
get to 1,800 that's the next goal and if
anybody else pledges tonight I will
still say thank you but we've reached
1,700 and I really appreciate that let's
listen to Andrew gillum's concession
speech here and forgot in Florida
conceded we have it as too close to call
but clearly they see otherwise
Rhonda sadhus apparently would go on to
be governor in floor west early surprise
there by the fact that Andrew Gilliam
was conceding saying he doesn't actually
see it that way let's let's see
necessarily see it that way let's see
what the numbers are looking that and
the good news is that in terms of
governor's I had predicted Democrats
plus one or two and they have gained
three so far so if you weren't with us
earlier in Michigan Democrats have taken
over the governorship Gretchen Whitmer
has won in Illinois JB Pritzker has
defeated incumbent Bruce rauner that is
plus two and in New Mexico New Mexico a
Michele Grisham has defeated Steve
Pearce plus three for Democrats but
sadly Andrew Gilliam
still not called forty nine point nine
two forty eight point nine with ninety
nine percent reporting yeah that's
that's not gonna go gillum's way
unfortunately and I do want to see
what's going on in the Senate in Florida
and it doesn't seem to be going well
there either
yeah Rick Scott is probably going to
defeat bill Nelson as well so not good
but part of what I predicted part of not
not nothing shocking has happened really
and that is I don't know if that's good
or bad but it just sort of is and there
it is PBS calling Florida for Ron de
santis over Andrew Gilliam at the
11 p.m. our thanks to Jackson for making
a five-dollar patreon contribution and
we are getting to the point where we
effectively know we have narrowed down
to just a very small variable now what
it is that is going to happen it is
indeed by every account going to be
Democrats taking over the house plus 14
so far they need plus 25 but every
indication that they are going to get it
the house has been called for Democrats
basically on on on almost all networks
that we're paying attention to in the
Senate Democrats are - - and my
prediction was they would be minus 1 or
minus 2 Republicans will keep control
there and it looks like Democrats are
indeed going to be about plus somewhere
between plus 1 and plus 3 it appears
when it comes to governor's a couple of
other super chats Messier 78 can you
check the Iowa House and governor seats
let's see what's going on in Iowa where
is I ok so house Iowa house yeah how is
our buddy JT Schulten doing in Iowa um
JT Schulten is up it's early man I want
JT sholden to win I met him in person
and hung out with him in New Orleans in
August at Netroots nation really good
guy running against one of the worst and
right now he's up but only 14% reporting
and you said governor in Iowa as well
let's take a look at that governor in
Iowa we've got Fred Hubbell up with 19%
reporting by 7 points over Kim Reynolds
that would be huge as well let's hope
that that becomes a reality uh Eric
Bechard I wanted to hear you stumble
over my name for a laugh but you got it
right and it turned out to be just as
satisfying Eric geese yard yeah that one
seems obvious to me thank you appreciate
the support
Matthew long says hey David love the
show keep up the good work
Francesca Boccaccio says I support
eloquence any day
what's with the dot ninety-nine like
what's the advantage to sending a dollar
ninety-nine
super chat over two bucks I just don't
know what what we've seen so many of
those and Polly foo-foo says thank you
for being here tonight David take my
call david has pledged $5.00 a month on
patreon and I am going to call it I am
unable to take more calls because I am
wrapping it up we do have a brand-new
show to do tomorrow thanks to everybody
who has joined me some big wins and some
unfortunate losses for Democrats thank
you it has been like almost four hours
of this nonsense but we did a lot of
great stuff tonight and we will have
full results tomorrow and analysis and
all of that stuff thanks to everybody
who joined me